Wann kann ich euch jetzt dann in der großen Hollywood-Produktion mit, ja ich weiß jetzt grad gar nicht, wie man sich da als Vater und wie man sich als Sohn wünschen könnte. Hast du schon mal Gedanken darüber gemacht, wer spielen soll?
Nein, ich kenne aber auch keine Schauspieler. Also wann, ich würde sagen in zwei Jahren vielleicht, vielleicht auch weniger.
Ich will meinen Lieblingsverein. Okay, ich fahre am Wochenende mit dir ins Stadion, wir gucken ein paar Spiele und als Gegenleistung lässt du dich in der Schule nicht mehr so provozieren.
Erste, zweite und dritte Liga, das sind 56 Vereine, die schauen wir uns alle zusammen an.
Wie, 56?
Es ist vier Jahre her, im Juli 2019, da haben wir uns zuletzt getroffen und wir haben uns sogar hier getroffen, hier in München. Ich freue mich sehr, dass bei mir sind die Wochenendrebellen, Mirco von Juterczenka und Jason von Juterczenka. Hallo ihr beiden. Ja, gleich müssen wir dieses Intro noch nachbesprechen, aber erst müssen wir gute Gastgeber sein, wollen wir gute Gastgeber sein. Und Andreas Thies hier begrüßen, endlich ist er mal im Rasenfunk, unglaublich wie lange das gedauert hat. Hallo Andreas, schön, dass du da bist.
Vielen Dank für die Einladung. Es ist einer der größten Träume, die in Erfüllung gegangen sind, endlich mal in den Rasenfunk zu kommen.
Jaja, und alle, die bei YouTube sind, die sehen, dass er fast nicht rot geworden ist, als er das gerade gesagt hat. Wir haben dich nämlich zugeschaltet. Ihr zwei, wir haben es ja gerade im Intro schon gehört und ich denke eigentlich, dass es die Leute da draußen auch schon mitbekommen haben sollten. Das, was wir da im Intro gehört haben, das ist jetzt wahr geworden. Jason, wie fühlt sich das für dich an? Konntest du dich noch erinnern an diesen Ausschnitt, als du mir vor vier Jahren prophezialt hast, in zwei Jahren ist der Film raus?
Ja, natürlich konnte ich mich erinnern. Ich musste fairerweise sagen, ich konnte nichts von der Pandemie wissen. Vielleicht wäre es in zwei Jahren gegangen, wenn da nichts gewesen wäre. So ist es jetzt vier Jahre geworden. Aber ja, ich kann mich daran erinnern und es ist ungefähr alles so gelaufen, wie ich es mir vorgestellt habe, würde ich sagen.
Cool, nicht schlecht. Also das mit den zwei Jahren war auch ein Witz. Das sollte kein Vorwurf sein. Mirco, konntest du das auch alles so abschätzen, was jetzt passiert ist?
Nein, nein. Also da sind wir auch mal wieder in der Perspektive dann doch unterschiedlich. Dieses Gefühl des Überrollwerdens, was jetzt gerade passiert, das deutete sich so nach und nach an. Aber Jason hat es von Anfang an prophezeit. Mal wieder.
Ja, wobei wir uns damals noch nicht einig waren, wir alle miteinander, ob es vielleicht eine Serie werden würde, weil Serien so hoch im Kurs standen. Aber es wurde ein Film, den Andreas und unter anderem deshalb bist du hier, nicht nur, weil ich dich endlich mal in den Rasenfunk holen wollte und es tut mir leid, deine Vereine bieten sich einfach nicht an, den du im Fußball anhängst, sondern weil du den Film auch schon gesehen hast. Willst du so einen ganz, ganz kurzen ersten Eindruck mal geben von dem, was du schon sehen konntest?
Also, da ich diese Geschichte der Wochenendrebellen ja schon relativ lange kannte, dann auch vor dem Film und dann auch vor eurem Gespräch, ich weiß gar nicht, wann wir uns kennengelernt haben, Mirco und ich haben uns in einem, im Broadbistro eines ICEs zwischen Würzburg und Kassel mal kennengelernt, wo auch sonst, da war ich, ich kannte die Geschichte ja schon länger und war relativ aufgeregt, als ich in diesen Film reingegangen bin, weil ich gedacht habe, es ist ein Film mit Florian David Fitz, wir kennen die Filmografie dann ja auch von Florian David Fitz, wo es dann darum geht, das sind zwischendurch dann durchaus mal Filme mit, mit ernsten Themen, Vincent Wilmea zum Beispiel, aber ist ja auch für Ja, ich bin sehr froh, dass ich die Zeit für die leichte Kost zwischendurch zu haben. Und da hatte ich ein bisschen die Angst, oh Gott, oh Gott, was wird das für ein Film werden? Und war allerdings wirklich sehr aufgeregt und bin hinterher aus dem Kino rausgegangen sehr zufrieden. Vor allen Dingen, wie gesagt, ich kannte die Geschichte und wie sie umgesetzt worden ist, fand ich wunderschön. Und das habe ich sofort Mirco dann auch hinterher noch geschrieben, dass ich den Film wirklich ganz, ganz toll fand.
Es können natürlich auch daran gelegen haben, dass du ihn mit dem perfekten Sitznachbarn geguckt hast. Also das muss man natürlich noch abziehen bei deiner Begeisterung. Denn wir haben ihn gemeinsam gesehen. Ich habe mich für diese Pressevorführung angemeldet. Und ich dachte mir noch schon, vielleicht trifft man ja da jemand und dann steht da ein zwei Meter großer Mensch und tröst mich freudig.
Und ich habe die ganze Zeit während des Films gedacht, kann ich ihn jetzt ansprechen oder ist er so konzentriert beim Filmgucken, dass ich ihn ansprechen darf. Aber wir haben uns ganz gut unterhalten während des Films.
Natürlich erst nach dem Film haben wir uns gut unterhalten.
Ja, aber zwischendurch dann auch die eine oder andere Szene.
Ja, ich muss auch sagen, wir waren beide angespannt, weil wir beide euch so gut kennen oder eure öffentlichen Personen so gut kennen und die Geschichte so gut kennen. Und ich muss sagen, deutscher Film manchmal cringe, Fußball im deutschen Film, super Cringe-Gefahr. Und Andreas nickt schon. Das ist tatsächlich, glaube ich, ganz gut gelungen. Also Andreas, vielleicht noch mal kurz deinen Eindruck. Und dann dürft ihr mal sagen, wie ihr das hinbekommen habt, denn da müsst ihr euer Finger mit dem Spiegel gehabt haben. Es war schon, hat alles schon so gepasst, so auch wie der Fußball und die Begeisterung dafür dargestellt wurde.
Also die Fußballszenen an sich waren wirklich fantastisch. Und das ist ja gerade auch in Sportfilmen immer das Schwierige. Kriegst du Darsteller oder Darstellerinnen, die den Sport beherrschen? Da kennt man aus den USA Baseballfilme, Goldfilme und so weiter, wo man gleich sieht, die Fußballer können es nicht, oder die Baseballspieler können es nicht. Und da muss man immer so einen Punkt abziehen. Aber diese Fußballszenen an sich in dem Film sind ja reell und da sind keine Szenen nachgespielt worden. Und das fand ich wirklich überragend. Und diese Stadionszene dann aus Dortmund, aus Nürnberg etc., das hat dem ganzen Film so einen Realitätslevel noch mal draufgegeben, dass man da überhaupt nicht drüber nachdenkt, ist das jetzt Cringe oder so, sondern das ist sehr, sehr natürlich in diesen Film eingefügt und macht das Ganze meiner Meinung nach dann noch ein kleines Stück sehenswerter.
So und jetzt müsst ihr uns sagen, wie ihr das geschafft habt. Wir wussten 2019 schon, dass quasi das Recht an eure Geschichte schon vergeben war, an den Autoren, den Drehbuchautoren Richard Kropf, der auch Four Blocks hat, der gemacht hat, glaube ich, unter anderem. Was ist seitdem passiert, dass jetzt dieser wahrscheinlich Blockbuster dabei rausgekommen ist?
Ja, Richard hat mir dann sein Drehbuch, seine erste Drehbuchversion zugeschickt und ich habe Rückmeldungen gegeben, wir haben Rückmeldungen gegeben. Diese Rückmeldungen kamen in Form einer zweistündigen Podcast-Datei, was nicht ganz so gut angekommen ist am Anfang, weil er wohl erst um die Länge gesehen hat und dann meinte, wollen wir den Film überhaupt noch machen? Aber als er die Datei sich dann angehört hat, hat er gemerkt, es ist vielleicht zehn Minuten Kritik und weit über eine Stunde weitere Ideen, Anregungen, Anmerkungen, Anekdoten dazu und das ging mehrmals hin und her mit den Drehbuchversionen, die wir bekommen haben und dann auch nach, als das Drehbuch fertig war, auch bei der Produktion des Films. Marc, also der Regisseur, hat jetzt neulich auf einer Premiere gesagt, er habe wohl noch nie eine so lange Liste mit Rückmeldungen erhalten wie von mir und das betrifft halt zum einen die Darstellung von Autismus zum Großteil, wo ich sehr viel noch Rückmeldungen gegeben habe, aber eben auch so unsere Reisen, um so zu wissen, wie läuft es so ab, wenn wir im Stadion sind und wie kann man dieses Feeling von unseren Touren so einfangen und in den Film wiedergeben und da habe ich eben sehr viel, also an gemeinsamen Ritualen, die wir haben auf unseren Touren, habe ich auch zur Verfügung gestellt, den Drehbuchautor, die im Buch zum Beispiel, in unserem Buch, gar nicht wirklich beschrieben wurden. Insofern ist es vielleicht ein bisschen mehr als eine reine Buchverfilmung, sondern es gibt noch zusätzliche Informationen von mir, die dort eingeflossen sind und das ist dann einfach sehr gut gelungen, dass so auch einzuarbeiten mit den Informationen, die ich noch gegeben habe.
Kannst du da ein Beispiel geben für so etwas, was wir noch nicht aus dem Buch kennen und noch nicht aus dem Podcast und so kennen, was aber im Film vorkommt?
Auf unseren Fußballreisen wird dort zum Beispiel gezeigt, die Luftblase, die Papsi so um mich bildet, wenn es sehr voll wird vor dem Stadion und um praktisch so Berührungen zu vermeiden. Das ist zum Beispiel ein Detail noch, das ergänzt wurde auf unseren Fußballreisen so. Und ansonsten ja noch viele andere Aspekte der Geschichte. Mein Forschungsprojekt kommt zum Beispiel kurz vor im Film, was im Buch keine Rolle spielt. Oder unsere Osteuropa-Tour, die ja, also wir haben ja auch ein Interview durch Osteuropa gemacht, die stattfand 2017, also nach der Erscheinung, nachdem wir das Buch geschrieben haben. Die wird so nicht eins zu eins übernommen, aber es gibt ein, also es gibt mehrere Szenen im Film, die praktisch die Erlebnisse der Osteuropa-Tour eigentlich darstellen. Genau, also mehr als tatsächlich nur im Buchstand.
Das hat er doch schon so gut zusammengefasst, dass es gar nicht so ganz viel zu ergänzen gibt. Aber es ist natürlich schon so, dass, was Andreas sagt, so diese Sorge, die er schon hatte, was passiert aus dieser Geschichte, die war bei mir natürlich auch vorhanden, überraschenderweise. Sodass wir mehrere Phasen hatten eigentlich, wo so dieses Thema Verfilmung, wohin geht, wohin geht da die Reise? Also ich meine, Verfilmung ist das eine. Dann hast du natürlich auch selbst so ein bisschen den Anspruch und dann versuchst du immer, okay, wie kriegst du jetzt die anderen dazu, dass dein Anspruch sich mit deren Anspruch deckt, weil unser Bestreben war, einen tollen Film zu machen und das war deren Bestreben sicherlich auch, mit dem zusätzlichen Aspekt, dass es vielleicht dann auch ein wirtschaftlicher Erfolg wird in irgendeiner Art und Weise, was natürlich dann bei Filmfördersummen und sonstigen in Größenordnung ist, wo man dann auch schnell weiß, wie man da mal unter die Räder geraten könnte gegebenenfalls. Und das war etwas, was mehr auch mein Part war als Jason's Part. Jason war wirklich so der Inputgeber und ich war eigentlich, ähnlich wie im Film, Papsi löst das Problem, so derjenige, der so diese, die Rahmenbedingungen schaffen muss, dass das eigentlich irgendwo geht und das war sicherlich nicht ganz einfach, aber wir haben das riesige Glück gehabt, Ahmet Richard von Beginn an jemanden zu haben, der mit sehr offenen Ohren, sehr aufmerksam und auch mit einer Behutsamkeit und Achtsamkeit an unsere Geschichte rangegangen ist, dass wir sehr schnell das Gefühl hatten, okay, der will die Geschichte wirklich erzählen. Wir hatten ja noch so zwei, drei andere Anfragen zu dem Zeitpunkt rund um die Verfilmung. Da war immer sehr schnell so das Gefühl, okay, da möchte jemand diese Geschichte kaufen, so nicht, dass es nicht ums Erzählen an sich ging. Dass dann so neben diesem Drehbuchprozess es gelingt, auch so in die Produktion, in die Postproduction etc. so einen Einfluss nehmen zu können, davon haben wir nicht zu träumen gewagt, da sind wir unendlich dankbar für. Weil das sicherlich A, total unüblich ist und B, halt jetzt zu der skurrilen Situation führt. Also wir waren letzte Woche bei bei Stern TV zu Gast, dass Florian David Fitz an dem Abend verstanden hat, dass das finale Werk so enorm nah an der Realität ist. Also das hat er wirklich, also es gibt so eine ganz kurze Szene, wo er so sagt, ach guck mal, ich hab ja sogar dieselbe Jacke an wie du, wo ich ihn an ein Gespräch erinnert habe, was wir von einem guten, gut anderthalb Jahren vielleicht hatten, wo ich gesagt hab, ja. Also für ihn war das erstmal ein Drehbuch. Aber ich mein, da sind Original-Dialoge drin von meiner Frau und mir, weil wir gesagt haben, ne, so streiten wir nicht, das muss halt eher so sein. Und als die ersten wissenschaftlichen Vorträge kamen in Thema A, B, C, hat Jason gesagt, ne, ne, ne, ne, das können wir so nicht machen, das muss so sein und so weiter. Und das ist total irre, wenn du es dann natürlich sowieso schon auf der Leinwand irgendwie so Teile deines Lebens verfilmt siehst und es dann noch so ist, dass dich plötzlich Eileen Tetzel genauso anguckt wie deine Frau und du merkst, oh man, die ist sauer. Das ist eine, mir fehlen da irgendwie so ein bisschen die Worte, das zu beschreiben, was da dann so in einem vorgeht. Das war sehr, sehr skurril, sehr, sehr skurril und ist es immer noch. Also ich bin froh, dass wir so viele Termine haben, weil man nie so richtig dazu kommt, mal das Ganze zu Revue passieren zu lassen.
Ganz kurz, das war, glaube ich, eine der ersten Sachen, die Andreas und ich uns zugeflüstert haben im Kino. Die Jacke kennen wir aber.
Genau. Und auch der Pullover ist uns nicht unbekannt gewesen.
Und da müssen wir aber jetzt, den Schwenk müssen wir jetzt doch noch schnell machen, bevor ihr weiter so ein bisschen von dem Entstehungs-Protest erzählt. Denn Andreas hat ja quasi das Casting betrieben. Ich habe das Casting betrieben.
Das ist auch eine Sache, die mir wirklich wichtig ist, in diesen Podcasts unterzubringen, dass ich das Casting übernommen habe für diesen Film. Weil Mirco hatte irgendwann mal auf Twitter gefragt, wer soll denn in Papsi spielen? Und dann hatte ich geantwortet, Florian David Fitz, und ja, wir müssen zugeben, du siehst so hübsch aus. Das war mein Tweet darauf. Das war meine Antwort darauf. Da kriegte ich gleich dann eine DM von Mirco und der schrieb mir dann, ja, der war sogar im Gespräch, aber ist aus dem und dem Grund, ist das wohl nicht realistisch. Und dann, als dann das Casting kam, bzw. als dann rauskam, wer die Hauptdarsteller sind, dann bin ich schon eine Ehrenrunde zu Hause, glaube ich.
Ja, ich erinnere mich sehr gut und ich erinnere mich auch sehr gut, dass sehr schnell kurz danach sich doch diese Favoritenrolle Richtung Florian sehr, sehr klar rauskristallisierte. Aber es war halt zu Beginn, als wir gesprochen haben oder als ich gefragt habe, da ging es eigentlich um das Abklopfen der ersten Namen so ganz vorsichtig. Da war, glaube ich, wenn ich mich nicht total täusche, war zu dem Zeitpunkt noch nicht mal das komplette Produktionsteam an Bord, sondern Richard wollte nur mal anfühlen, wer darf es denn vielleicht gar nicht sein und wer käme so infrage. Und ich habe jetzt sehr früh bei meiner Rolle gesagt, dass ich gesagt habe, wir haben bei Jason so einen hohen Anspruch, wen ihr da für mich findet, ist mir eigentlich fast egal. Es gab so einen Namen, den wir zum Glück alle so sofort ausschließen konnten, wo ich gesagt habe, das wäre jetzt nicht so toll, aber ansonsten bin ich da sehr offen. Und ja gut, dass es tatsächlich dann am Ende Florian wird, ist auf so vielen Ebenen schon wieder cringe, weil die Rahmenbedingung war, es sollte schon jemand sein, der sich richtig gut mit Fußball auskennt. Florian David Fitzhaw, wirklich Null Ahnung von Fußball, das ist unglaublich. Und all diese Dinge, die dann fast in der Hand sind, also diese gesamte Cast ist ja gigantisch und das natürlich mit Beginn Florian, war dann auch für mich so ein bisschen klar, okay, der Film wird eine größere Hausnummer. Das ist ja per se erstmal jemand, wo man weiß, okay, das wird jetzt kein Film, der so unterferner lief, irgendwie im kleinen Arthouse-Kino läuft und dann nach zwei Wochen wieder verschwindet.
Darf ich einmal gerade eine Frage stellen, wo wir gerade beim Casting sind und ihr habt diese Geschichte schon, du Jason und mir, habt die Geschichte dann auch schon häufiger erzählt, dass ihr als ihr Cecilio das erste Mal gesehen habt, dass ihr sofort gesagt habt, der und sonst keiner. Wie viele Jasens habt ihr vorher gesehen, bevor ihr den Cecilio Jason gesehen habt und bevor ihr ihn dann wirklich dann auch identifiziert habt als den, der Jason dann spielen soll?
Also bevor Jason gleich sagt, wie viele es waren, sage ich gegebenenfalls mal, was so unsere Rahmenbedingungen waren. Wir haben gesagt, wir wollen nicht den gesamten Casting-Prozess begleiten insgesamt, sondern wir wären froh, dort ein gewisses Mitspracherecht zu haben, haben aber da insgesamt schon auch eher das Vertrauen, dass ihr besser wisst, was richtig ist oder in welche Richtung das geht. Wie viel Cetus oder wie viel, wie viel Jasens wir gesehen haben, kann Jason ja dann erklären und auch vielleicht so ein bisschen, was dann in ihm vorgegangen ist. Genau. Wir haben nur Ceto gesehen. Wir haben wirklich nur Ceto gesehen und sonst niemanden. Und umso gigantischer war es, dass das auch trotzdem etwas war in einer Qualität, wo er saß sofort auf dem Sessel und hat gesagt, boah, ist der gut, der muss das machen. Also das war so nach, ich glaube es liefen drei oder vier Sekunden Szene und es ging um die Nudelbistro-Szene insgesamt und dort auch die Phase der Eskalation und mir lief sofort eiskalt den Rücken runter, weil ich gesagt habe, boah, das ist so nah an dem, es ist ja zudem auch eine der Szenen, die wirklich eins zu eins so passiert ist. Das war mega spooky und wir haben die Szene gesehen und ich glaube, eine gute halbe Stunde später ging die Mail raus, der oder keiner und ja, es ist dann zum Glück geworden, was aber auch insbesondere Marke Rothemann zu verdanken ist, der dann da sehr viel in Bewegung setzen musste, weil Drehen mit Kindern etc. natürlich auch hinsichtlich Zeiten und Co. nicht immer so ganz einfach ist.
Also Cecilio Andresen ist quasi C2 und die Szene im Bordbistro, diejenigen, die euer Buch gelesen haben, die können sich erinnern, alle anderen kaufen es bitte jetzt sofort. Ich rechne eh damit, dass dieses Buch jetzt noch mal durch den Film ganz schön weit nach oben schießt. Ich habe meiner Buchhändlerin hier in München schon bereit, habe ich ihr schon bereits gesagt. Ein Exemplar wird nicht reichen, was du hier gerade stehen hast. Grüße an dieser Stelle. Die Bordbistro Szene, da geht es eben darum, dass ja Jason, du möchtest, dass sich Essen nicht berührt beim Essen und dass vorher sogar noch die Anweisung oder diese Information wird weitergegeben an den Kellner dort und dann berührt sich das Essen eben doch und das führt dann zu so einem Overload bei dir und ist eben deswegen so eine der Schluss-Szenen, weil sie glaube ich auch so eindrücklich ist und das war es ja schon in der Beschreibung im Buch und im Film hat man auch das Gefühl, da mit so zwei, drei weiteren Szenen, da wird eben versucht darzustellen, was in der Außenwelt, was die Außenwelt sieht und was dann aber auch bei dir passiert. Und deswegen wird mich interessieren, wie fühlt sich das denn für dich an, dass jemand anderes dich spielt, dass jemand anders auch quasi das, was ja gar nicht mehr so einfach in Worte zu fassen ist, umsetzen soll?
Also grundsätzlich war das schon eigentlich einer meiner Wünsche, mich selbst irgendwie so kennenzulernen und mich selbst auf der Leinwand zu sehen und mit mir selbst sogar befreundet zu sein, das habe ich mir schon immer cool vorgestellt. Und das ist durch den Film ja so ein bisschen wahr geworden. Das Ding ist halt auch, also die Nudelszene jetzt beispielsweise in Bordbistro, die zu schauen hat tatsächlich so wehgetan irgendwie, weil ich ja noch das, ich erinnere mich noch an das Gefühl. Und es war nicht, also es war definitiv wahrscheinlich schlimmer als es dort tatsächlich sogar noch dargestellt. Also die Eskalation war intensiver als sie dargestellt wurde im Film. Weiß nicht, ob das gemacht wurde, damit der Film nicht FSK 18 wird oder so, von der Wortwahl. Aber es war eigentlich so noch intensiver. Und das dann wieder so zu sehen, auch so nah an der Realität und mit Cito, der ja das auch auf dieselbe Art gesprochen hat wie ich und sich auf dieselbe Art gestikuliert hat, wie ich das gemacht habe und sich eins zu eins verhalten hat wie ich. Ja, war das auch besonders eindrücklich irgendwie. Er hat bei so eher unangenehmen Szenen dann halt auch total wieder ein unangenehmes Gefühl hochkommen lassen. Aber in den sehr positiven Szenen, die ich ja auch noch eins zu eins in Erinnerung habe, wie sie in der Realität passiert sind, durchlebt man ja auch diese Szenen irgendwie nochmal. Das heißt, in jedem Fall ist es eigentlich immer spooky, aber oft ist es halt auch sehr, sehr positiv. Und insgesamt ist natürlich klar, dass allein schon die Tatsache, dass selbst eine so unangenehme Szene in der Lage ist, mich dieses Gefühl noch einmal durchleben zu lassen, ist ja schon eigentlich ein Beweis dafür, dass sie gut gelungen ist.
Das ist wirklich krass, muss ich sagen. Ich will auch gar nicht wissen, wie das ist, quasi Erinnerungen des eigenen Lebens nochmal umgesetzt zu sehen in perfekter Ausleuchtung und mit verschiedenen Kameraperspektiven und dann zoomt die Kamera nochmal an dein bzw. an Florian David Fitzs Gesicht heran und du sitzt im Kinosessel oder wahrscheinlich die erste Mal habt ihr es ja wahrscheinlich noch woanders gesehen und man denkt sich so, ach so, ja so hat das wahrscheinlich von außen aus gesehen, an was ich mich erinnere.
Ja gut, da ist Kino natürlich schon nochmal eine Hausnummer, die mich völlig aus den Socken gehauen hat. Wir haben den Film irgendwie ein Dutzendmal gesehen oder tausende von Szenen dann aus unterschiedlichsten Perspektiven und haben dann quasi bei der Premiere in Berlin erstmals die im Kino die Kino-Variante gesehen. Das ist halt schon gerade so bei den Stadionszenen oder bei diesen sehr intensiven Szenen etwas ähnlich wie Jason so sagte. Du bist halt schon nochmal voll drin und mich hat so in diesen Sessel gepresst. Ich hab also während der Premiere Berlin saß, ich die ganze Zeit hab nicht nach links, nicht nach rechts, nur irgendwie versuchte mit meinem Leben klarzukommen, weil man nie so wusste, wer beobachtet dich jetzt gerade, wenn du hier wieder rotz und Wasser heulst oder so. Das war sehr, sehr spooky.
Das war auch die intensivste Szene, fand ich, im gesamten Film. Es gibt diverse, die intensive Szene. Die Toiletten-Szene zum Beispiel finde ich auch extrem intensiv, auch das in dem Stadion dort bei der Osteuropa-Tour. Aber diese Szene, finde ich, dampft das Ganze so ein bisschen zusammen auf die Essenz, auf den Krieg im Kopf bzw. dann auch auf die ganzen Situationen, die ausgehalten werden müssen, dann ja auch von euch beiden. Und das, fand ich, war die intensivste Szene. Und da habe ich mich, selbst ich mich, der unbeteiligter bin und der nur einen Film geguckt hat über zwei Menschen, die ich halt kenne und deren öffentliches Leben ich kenne. Aber selbst da war ich sehr angespannt und habe meine Finger in den Sessel gekrallt.
Ja und Andreas, ich weiß nicht, ob dir das auch so ging wie mir. Wir kannten ja quasi Teile der Szenen schon. Und zwar einmal aus persönlicher Erzählung, dann aus wie es im Buch niedergeschrieben ist. Und dann haben wir es im Rahmen von Lesung ja dann quasi nochmal erzählt bekommen. Und für mich war das so eindrucksvoll, dass ihr erzählt das ja immer humorvoll. Mirco, du hast ja auch im Buch so einen humorvollen Ton, im Blog ja auch immer. Und das scheint ja auch so ein bisschen so dein Coping-Mechanismus zu sein in manchen Situationen. Und das dann aber noch mal so nah zu erleben, zum Beispiel auch die Bushaltestellenszene. Das ist glaube ich so eine weitere Schlussszene. Ganz früh im Film kommt ja deswegen auch ein Trailer vor, denke ich, um einfach zu erklären, wie sieht es nach außen aus, was Jason erlebt und welche Probleme macht das eben für euch Angehörige, die wissen, die ungefähr sich vorstellen können, wie es aussieht, aber für die Außenwelt, die da drauf erstmal in allen möglichen Facetten reagieren kann. Also mir hat das noch mal klar gemacht, wie schön ich mir das eigentlich auch oft gedacht hatte. Also wie heftig das einfach im wirklichen Leben ist. Und ich hätte das natürlich wissen müssen, aber dadurch, dass ihr das immer so locker und humorvoll erzählt und ja auch durchaus mit einer Prise Selbstironie, gerade wenn man auch euren Podcast gehört hat. Also ich weiß nicht, Andreas, ob du das ähnlich hattest, aber ich habe da manche Dinge zum ersten Mal erst so richtig verstanden, wie das eigentlich ungefähr gewesen sein könnte.
Also die Wucht dieser Darstellung und die Wucht der Umsetzung dann, diese Szenen, die man vorher nur gelesen, schrägstrich gehört hat, die hat mich dann auch schon wirklich beeindruckt, aber gerade diese Breutbistro-Szene habe ich mir, der ich sehr zu auch Fremdscham neige und sehr dann auch angespannt bin in Situationen, die vielleicht für manche gar nicht so unangenehm sind für mich, habe ich schon extrem, schon als ich es gelesen habe, nachvollziehen können und das entfaltet da aber nochmal im Film eine ganz besondere Wucht und das war etwas, was ich mir schon heftig vorgestellt habe und was dann im Film sogar für mich noch ein kleines bisschen heftiger rauskam.
Jason, gab es das bei dir auch, dass du noch mal Dinge gesehen hast und ich meine, du hast ja schon angedeutet, dass da manche Szenen wieder so einen kleinen Trigger gesetzt haben, weil du dich einfach so gut wieder reinversetzen konntest. Gibt es Dinge, die im Film vielleicht sogar sich noch heftiger für dich angefühlt haben, weil du auch eben es zum ersten Mal ja auch aus der Außenperspektive nachvollziehen konntest?
Noch heftiger, ich würde sagen in der Regel ist die Innenperspektive ja irgendwie heftiger als die Außenperspektive, deswegen glaube ich nicht, dass es eine Szene gibt, die noch intensiver wirkt, als ich sie in Erinnerung habe, sondern in der Regel sind die Szenen entweder treffen sie es eins zu eins oder sie sind halt ein bisschen abgemildert aus irgendwelchen Gründen, aber selbst dann hat es halt immer noch genügt, um solche Gefühle irgendwie wieder zu durchleben. Also natürlich die Nudelszene ist dort ein Beispiel, aber es gibt ja praktisch die Schlussszene, die entspricht auch eins zu eins der Realität, weil ich in der fünften Klasse mal, als ich auf eine neue Schule gekommen bin, habe ich einmal einen Vortrag gehalten, praktisch vor meiner Klasse, wo ich meinen Autismus erklärt habe und praktisch so ein bisschen die Strategie gewechselt habe, ganz offen zu kommunizieren und mich damit vielleicht angreifbar zu machen, aber gleichzeitig auch sicher sein zu können, dass niemand mehr aus Unwissenheit oder so Fehler macht, sondern dass diejenigen, die es jetzt noch machen, es bewusst machen. Das war ja auch in der Realität ein ganz zentrales Erlebnis, womit die Reaktionen und das positive Resultat mich dann ja auch insgesamt daran bestätigt haben, diese offensive Kommunikation auch in Richtung der Öffentlichkeit zu fahren. Und diesen Vortrag von außen zu sehen, war auch ziemlich eindrucksvoll. Weil der ja praktisch sogar, also bei den anderen Szenen muss man sagen, hat es mich nie groß interessiert, wie sie sich von außen wahrgenommen werden eigentlich. Weil ja, das hat ja keinen Einfluss auf mich. Also wie die anderen Menschen im Bordbistro das jetzt fanden, war nicht in der Top 50 meiner Gedanken in diesem Moment. Und so ist das bei vielen Szenen. Aber bei diesem Vortrag ging es ja gerade darum, also da ging es darum, der war adressiert an die Menschen, die ihn hören. Und deswegen war es da am interessantesten zu sehen, wie es von außen aussah.
Und warst du zufrieden mit deinem Vortrag?
Ja, ich habe den Vortragstext Richard nämlich eins zu eins geschickt, so wie ich ihn gehalten habe. Also der Filmvortrag ist derselbe wie der in der Realität. Und ich bin mit beiden dementsprechend sehr zufrieden.
Das ist schon absolut faszinierend, wie nah Richard Kopf versucht hat, an der Realität zu bleiben. Das ist, glaube ich, auch wirklich nicht selbstverständlich, wenn man weiß, wie viel getweekt werden muss oft an Geschichten. Und ich meine, das gibt es ja im Kleinen im Film auch. Ich meine, die Rasenfunk-Hörerinnen und Hörer, die kennen euch schon länger. 2019 wart ihr hier und ihr wart ja extrem spät im Rasenfunk, was an mir lag. Also wir haben zwei Jahre lang, glaube ich, diese Sendung geplant. Und dann hat sie endlich irgendwann mal geklappt. Und im Film merkt man das daran, dass eben manchmal Dinge so in eine andere zeitliche Abfolge gestellt werden, damit es auch der Dramaturgie eines Filmes folgt. Das muss ja alles ein bisschen schneller gehen. Wie konntest du damit umgehen, Mirco, dass da auch manchmal dann eine harte Entscheidung getroffen werden musste?
Das ging eigentlich gut, weil wir, also Richard und ich hatten, oder Richard und wir beide hatten sehr früh, hat er uns auch so ein bisschen mitgenommen, was ist die Herausforderung für ihn in seiner Rolle als Drehbuchautor, dass er gesagt hat, hey Mirco, wir haben nur einen Jason. Wir haben keinen sechsjährigen, siebenjährigen, achtjährigen, zehnjährigen, elfjährigen. Das heißt, es gibt insgesamt erst mal so eine zeitliche Verdichtung von einem Zeitfenster von vier oder fünf Jahren, was ja dafür sorgt, dass im Film wir eigentlich hintereinander weg, Woche für Woche so diese Stadion wegammeln. So war es ja nicht in der Realität. Sondern wir haben ja dann doch schon uns ein wenig mehr Zeit genommen. Und wir haben so an Rahmenbedingungen so das eine oder andere abgesteckt. Das war halt einmal die Figur Jason, wo wir gesagt haben, da ist ein absolutes Maß an Authentizität wichtig. Und das Zweite, dass wir gesagt haben, Jason wird in dieser Rolle dann oder der Film Jason wird schon auch, gerade durch die enge Verbindung, Buchverfilmung etc., schon auch Gefahr laufen, als Art Role Model im Autismus gegebenenfalls zu laufen. Was natürlich dann aus ganz vielen Perspektiven heraus erst mal auch wieder ein Problem darstellt. A, es sind wieder die zwei Männer, die unterwegs sind, während die Frauen so im Hintergrund stehen, das war das eine Thema. Und das Zweite war, dass wir gesagt haben, es ist halt enorm wichtig, dass uns nicht der Hauch eines Fehlers im Film passiert, weil wenn der dann erst mal raus ist, ist er halt raus. Also dann gibt es da große Probleme. Und da waren wir A, sehr aktiv, was halt ungewöhnlich ist einerseits, und B, aber auch, dass wir so aktiv sein dürfen und halt auch so offene Ohren stoßen, insbesondere so in diesem gesamten Drehbuchprozess. Das war schon außergewöhnlich, das war wirklich weit weg von normal. Richard rief dann an, es gibt dann so ganz viele Momente, wo er sagt, ich habe die und die Problematik, hier braucht es noch irgendwie was weiß ich, noch mal im Tiefpunkt, noch mal so einen Ansatz oder so einen Ansatz. Und er hat halt immer so den Ansatz gehabt, ich möchte nicht fiktionalisieren, sondern gibt es irgendwas, was ihr ähnlich so erlebt habt, sodass also, ja gut, ich will jetzt auch nicht zu viel spoilern, aber halt Dinge dann gegebenenfalls von der Osteuropa Tour oder Momente von dort genommen wurden. Und daraus ergibt sich so eine total skurrile Situation, dass es sehr, sehr viel gibt, was entweder original Dialoge tatsächlich sind von uns, weil wir sie vorgegeben haben und sie über den Drehbuchprozess hinaus dann auch wirklich es in den Filmen geschafft haben, zusätzlich aber auch selbst bei verdichteten Momenten es eigentlich immer so einen realen Bezug gibt irgendwo. Das heißt, es gibt eigentlich im gesamten Film keine Szene, wo ich nicht zumindest sagen könnte, okay, da hat hier, hier und hier noch drei Anknüpfungspunkte, auch wenn es natürlich aus dramaturgischen Gründen, ich kriege eins auf die Nase im Film, das ist uns nie passiert. Und das war trotzdem sehr früh in der Drehbuchversion. Es sollte am Anfang im Stadion passieren, wo wir gesagt haben, das wiederum finden wir jetzt nicht so gut, weil wir haben in 100 Spielen im Stadion, es ist nichts passiert. Warum muss jetzt der Fußballfan im Stadion wieder der sein, der uns dann, der Böse, der uns eins auf die Nase gibt, sodass man gesagt hat, okay, lass uns das so ein bisschen rausladen. Also egal was war, man hat sich da immer so auf uns eingelassen und hat verstanden, was, wieso, weshalb, warum uns auch wichtig ist, dass das nicht irgendwie der Ego-Trip von Mirco und Jason ist, die jetzt sagen, dass wir wollen aber so dargestellt werden, sondern konnten eigentlich immer relativ gut argumentieren, entweder hinsichtlich unserer Verantwortung, was die Kommunikation über Autismus allgemein angeht oder halt auch einfach Dinge, wo wir gesagt haben, nee, das möchten wir aus persönlichen Gründen nicht oder so. Und da sind uns alle bis zum Schluss entgegengekommen. Also es war wirklich spooky, auch wenn die Begeisterung in manchen Phasen sich natürlich in Grenzen hielt. Das ist jetzt auch nicht so ein kontinuierlicher Feel-good-happy-Prozess oder so, sondern ich kann mich da schon erinnern, dass es auch Phasen gab, wo ich gesagt habe, was wird aus diesem Film oder was passiert da mit uns gerade.
Jason, jetzt bist du ja jemand, der logischerweise sehr sich an Regeln hält und ja auch dementsprechend möglichst akkurat viele Dinge wiedergegeben werden möchte. Also zum Beispiel du schickst den kompletten Vortrag an den Drehbuchautor und er ist dann so toll, dann auch wirklich Sätze daraus quasi zu verwenden. Wie ist es dir damit gegangen, dass ja manche Dinge dann doch geändert werden mussten?
Also es war gar nicht so, dass ich bei den Szenen, wo zum Beispiel meine 1 zu 1 Texte übernommen wurden, dass ich darauf verstanden habe, sondern es wurde vielmehr an manchen Stellen sogar angefordert. Also die Verantwortlichen am Film waren teilweise auch dankbar dafür. Und ich würde sagen, es hat den Film auch verbessert. Und die Stellen, wo dann dramatisiert werden musste, war ich dann auch so weit zu sagen, davon verstehe ich wiederum nicht so viel von Dramaturgie und wie man letztlich einen Film dreht. Also lasse ich dort auch den in den Freiraum, die es so besser wissen. Die Regel war halt einfach, dass die Dramaturgie auf keinen Fall auf Kosten der Darstellung von Autismus und der Darstellung meiner Persönlichkeit geschehen darf. Das war die einzige Bedingung und jenseits dessen also diese Kompaktifizierung von mehreren Jahren oder Dinge an einen anderen Ort verlegen oder die Chronologie umtauschen, wenn das dem Film nützt, dann war ich da auch immer offen, das so zu machen, weil ich natürlich auch will, dass der Film jetzt nicht unterhaltsam wird. Und mein Anspruch war, dass das Feeling auf unseren Reisen so wiedergegeben wird und dass meine Persönlichkeit wiedergegeben wird und solange das erfüllt war, konnte ich auch mit einem gewissen Maß an Entfremdung leben. Wobei es mich natürlich immer gefreut hat, wenn ich irgendwie tatsächlich so eins zu eins den wieder entdeckt habe. Das ist natürlich ein schönes Gefühl.
Ist dir das schwergefallen, die auch so ein bisschen die Führung dann abzugeben, weil ihr gebt euch ja in die Hände von Drehbuchautoren. Ja, ihr habt jetzt beide dann auch klar gemacht, dass die Absprache oder die Zusammenarbeit da fantastisch war. Aber ist dir das zwischendurch schwergefallen, dass du gesagt hast, das würde ich schon gerne selber machen? Also auch wenn du gesagt hast, ich habe keine Ahnung von Dramaturgie, aber dass man sagt, ich muss das jetzt in andere Hände geben, ist dir das schwergefallen?
Naja, unterm Strich hätte ich es nicht besser gekonnt. Von daher nicht so wirklich. Und das liegt aber auch zum Großteil an den Leuten, in deren Hände wir es ja gegeben haben. Also normalerweise wäre das was, womit ich mich wenig wohlfühle tatsächlich. Weil bei so etwas Wichtigem müsste ich einer Person schon sehr vertrauen, um ihr das so in die Hände zu geben. Und müsste die Gewissheit haben, dass dann ich irgendwie noch den Draht dazu habe und im Zweifel ich ernst genommen werde, wenn ich wirklich einen dringenden Wunsch habe, der so, also das etwas so zum Beispiel gar nicht funktioniert. Aber bei Richard jetzt für das Drehbuch wusste ich halt erstens, dass er halt einen guten Job machen wird, weil ich ja vorher mit ihm gesprochen habe, bevor er angefangen hat das Drehbuch zu schreiben und ihn kennengelernt habe und mich aus dem Gespräch mitnehmen konnte, er wird das gut machen. Und gleichzeitig ja sein Wort hatte mehr oder weniger, dass ich dort auch eingebunden werde und ich sagen kann, wenn etwas nicht geht. Und beides hat mich dann dazu gebracht, dass es nicht schwer war. Und ähnliches galt dann für die anderen Menschen, mit denen wir zusammen gearbeitet haben, später. Also mit Marc und dann halt mit dem Filmteam bis heute, ja.
Andreas, wir haben dich ja nicht nur hier mit dabei, weil wir gemeinsam die Premiere sehen durften und weil ich dich endlich mal zum Rasenfunk haben wollte, sondern du hast ja auch noch ein Interview geführt mit den beiden Hautdarstellern Aileen Taizel und Florian David Fitz, bevor wir da mal so ein paar O-Tone hören und dann darüber auch gerne sprechen können. Welchen Eindruck haben die beiden dann auch quasi in ihrer Rolle? Du hast sie erst im Film gesehen, dann hast du sie darüber sprechen hören. Welchen Eindruck haben sie auf dich gemacht?
Also mein Eindruck war wirklich ganz hervorragend, weil ich war vorher dann auch so ein bisschen unsicher. Ich bin im Sportjournalismus tätig, Filmjournalismus ist nun wirklich überhaupt gar nicht mein Ding, weil ich auch nicht der größte Kinogänger bin. Deswegen war ich da schon relativ unsicher. Dann war das Interview dann auch noch im Bayerischen Hof in München angesetzt, in einem der größeren Säle und dann hatte das wirklich etwas und das habe ich den beiden auch sofort gesagt. Es hatte was von Notting Hill, wo Hugh Grant dann gegenüber sitzt von Julia Roberts und wo es dann heißt hier die Leser von Horsenhaut werden sich dafür bedanken für dieses Interview. Also da habe ich schon erstmal so ein bisschen Respekt davor gehabt, aber die beiden waren tatsächlich sehr angenehm und haben auch, also die 20 Minuten Interview, die ich mit denen gemacht habe, sie haben den Eindruck hinterlassen, dass sie hinter dem Film total stehen und dass sie auch sehr gerne über diesen Film gesprochen haben. Und das fand ich, war bemerkenswert vor allen Dingen. Es war vier Monate, es war im Juni oder Juli, dass ich mit den beiden gesprochen habe. Es war noch Monate vor der Premiere und beide waren schon sehr in Vorfreude. Aileen Tetzel hat noch ein anderes Projekt gehabt als Regisseurin, Florian David Fitz hat auch noch einen anderen Film gehabt, den er promoten musste. Aber trotzdem haben beide sich sehr auf diesen Film gefreut und das kam in jeder Sekunde dieses Gespräch dann raus. Und das war ein sehr angenehmes Gespräch.
Das kann ich bestätigen als derjenige, der es auch komplett hören durfte. Dann hören wir doch mal rein. Es ist ein Thema, das haben wir gerade schon ein bisschen gestreift. Aber jetzt wollen wir Florian David Fitz doch noch mal selber darüber reden hören, wie viel er eigentlich von Fußball versteht.
Ich war einmal tatsächlich im Olympiastadion damals noch, aber ich war wirklich wie Jason. Ich war der Einzige, der nicht mehr stehen wollte. Ich saß dann einfach, als mich irgendwann genervt hat zu stehen. Also ich gucke Weltmeisterschaft, aber das ist ja wie wenn du sagst, du gehst Weihnachten in die Kirche. Ich bin aber auch derjenige, der nach dem Endspiel in der Weltmeisterschaft sich wundert, dass die selben, die gerade gegeneinander gespielt haben, schon wieder für die Vorauswahl für die EM miteinander spielen. Ich so, warte, es ist doch völlig sinnlos, lass das doch einmal kurz stehen. Weil dann spielen die ganz oft wieder gegeneinander und dann ist es plötzlich anders. Und dann denkst du dir, es ist alles doch wirklich nur bis hin dann auch wieder so Zufall. Und dann kommen die Leute mit ihren ganzen Vereinen und Champions League und so. Und da musste ich mich immer aufklären, weil ich es einfach überhaupt gar nicht verstehe. Und ich sage ja dann auch alle Vereine falsch. Aber ich hatte ja wirklich jetzt, habt ihr jetzt wahnsinnig viel mitbekommen. Also für mich war das sehr, wir sind ja da in diese ganzen Stadien auch reingegangen. Für mich war das wahnsinnig lehrreich und witzigerweise auch viel liebevoller und interessanter, als ich mir das vorgestellt habe. Oder ich hatte mir gar nichts vorgestellt. Wie unterschiedlich das ist, mit wie viel Freude da reingegangen wird. Weil ich ja immer gedacht habe, Leute verdreschen sich dann da vorm Stadion und trinken Bier und grünen. Aber es ist ja so viel Liebe zu diesem Verein, das ich ja gar nicht kenne. Wahrscheinlich bin ich sowieso ein Blinder, der einfach nie gesehen hat.
Vorauswahl für die EM. Also mehr musste Florian David Fitts nicht sagen.
Ja, und ihr habt einen Blinden zum Sehen gebracht, Mirco.
Ja, und vor allen Dingen, das ist also kein Promo-Talk oder sonstiges. Wir hatten da letzte Woche zwei Tage hintereinander sehr viele Termine, wo wir zwischendurch warten mussten. Und da haben wir auch noch mal drüber gesprochen, wo er schon nochmal sagt, er hatte das erste Mal so das Gefühl, dass er nachvollziehen kann, dass es vielleicht da etwas gibt, was ihm fehlt irgendwo. Das war total spannend zu hören und zu sehen. Also ich glaube, eine der ersten Drehs war dann Union Alte Försterei, wo es ihn dann schon wohl gesagt hat, okay, das ist was anderes als das, was ich erwartet habe. Und er sagte, als dann die Süd kam, also der Auftritt in Dortmund, hat er gesagt, okay, das macht halt schon was mit dir, wenn da so diese Kulisse mit allem, was super, super spannend. Also wirklich von jemanden, der glaubhaft so wenig Ahnung hat vom Vereinsfußball und sich so wenig auch dafür interessiert, dann doch so ein bisschen gecatcht wird von diesem Ganzen. Und ich habe gesagt, du, ich bin mit Jason noch nicht fertig, aber wenn er Bock hat, nehmen wir ihn dann mit und suchen für ihn auch noch einen Lieblingsverein.
Sehr schön, dann steht er zu dritt irgendwann auf der Tribüne. Jason, wie zufrieden bist du mit deinem Film Papsi?
Beim Film Papsi, ich würde sagen, der ist schon sehr gut getroffen. Man muss ja immer so ein bisschen unterscheiden zwischen der Darstellung praktisch des Schauspielers und dem Inhalt, das ja schon im Drehbuch festgelegt wird. Und Papsi ist schon ein bisschen mehr entfremdet als ich, weil ich bin eigentlich gar nicht entfremdet. Und bei Papsi gibt es schon einige Sätze, die er nicht nur nicht gesagt hat, sondern die er wahrscheinlich auch so hätte nicht sagen können oder nie gesagt. Auch, ja. Und so die Art, auf die wir zum Beispiel streiten, ist anders als in der Realität. Aber so insgesamt, so seine Umgang mit mir und seine Problemlösungsstrategien und wie er dann reagiert und wie er so dazulernend von Spielbesuch zu Spielbesuch, wie wir beide irgendwie so dazulernen. Und dann auch die Art, auf die er in solchen Situationen halt versucht, auf mich einzuwirken, ist auch schon nah an der Realität. Ich merke natürlich so die eine oder andere kleine Abweichung an manchen Stellen, weil ich halt ja eins zu eins die Realität kenne und genau weiß, wie es war. Und dann weiß ich zum Beispiel, dass Papsi in solchen Situationen wie bei der Nudelszene war ja manchmal nicht ganz so besonnen, wie es vielleicht im Film dargestellt wird, sondern hat am Anfang auch noch irgendwie den Drang, sich bei der Umgebung zu entschuldigen, weil er mit der Zeit erst nachgelassen hat und aufgehört hat. Aber im Großen und Ganzen wird sowohl der Prozess, also die Entwicklung seines Charakters, als auch seine Art, mit mir umzugehen, schon ziemlich gut dargestellt.
Und ich fand es so interessant, Andreas, an dem, was Florian David Fitz da gesagt hat, zum einen, welche Klischees über Fußballfans auch bei jemanden verfangen, der vielleicht tiefer in so mancher Ecke drinsteckt als wir. Und zum anderen aber auch, dass das schon eine der Sachen ist, die dieser Film schaffen kann, nämlich Fan-Kultur und eben erst mal das Fan-Dasein darzustellen. Es ist ja gar nicht im engeren Sinn ein Fußballfilm, sondern ein Fußballfan-Film.
Ist es. Und das ist auch eine Geschichte, die mir sehr gut an den Film gefallen hat, dass ich gedacht habe, es ist keine Fan-Szene oder so, also Fan-Szene im Film, dabei, wo man gedacht hat, da wird die Fanschaft jetzt in irgendeiner Weise dargestellt in einer Form, wo man sagt, okay, das entspricht jetzt ein bisschen dem Klischee. Und das fand ich dann auch sehr nett an dem Film, dass wirklich die Begeisterung darüber kommt und das wirklich dann auch, Joachim Kroll macht das ja zum Beispiel auch in dieser Szene, wo er erzählt, na ja, einen Verein, den hat man aus der Heimatstadt oder wo man geboren ist etc. Wo er das dann wirklich sehr authentisch darstellt, dass man vielleicht gar nicht immer so 100% erklären kann, warum einem der Lieblingsverein da gegeben worden ist oder warum man ihn bekommen hat. Aber es ist nie so in irgendeiner Weise peinlich abdriften, sodass man sagt, okay Leute, also mehr Klischee hättet ihr jetzt für die Fans dann auch nicht bringen können. Und das fand ich dann auch sehr nett. Und dass Florian David Fitz wirklich glaubhaft keine Ahnung von Fußball hat, in einer Stadt in München, in der er geboren und aufgewachsen ist, wo er in die Schule gegangen ist, wo er in einer Zeit aufgewachsen ist dann ja auch noch, wo 1860 München ja auch noch ein veritabler Gegenkandidat war für den FC Bayern. Das ist wirklich besonders und das ist bemerkenswert.
Das ist wirklich bemerkenswert. Und gleichzeitig haben wir mit Joachim Kroll noch Opa Gerd quasi angesprochen, der auch mit vorkommt im Film. Fand ich ganz interessant, es ist ja so ein bisschen ein, jetzt fällt mir der Fachbegriff, da finde ich auch, ein Kammerspiel oder so ähnlich, also quasi sehr wenige Figuren, die dann aber auf eine Reise gehen, dann ist es ein Roadmovie. Und ich habe das Gefühl, dass gerade die Großelternfiguren auch so eine abfangende Rolle spielen. Also zum Beispiel sind sie zugegen, ich weiß nicht, ob es in der Wahrheit auch so war, beim großen Streit zwischen Aileen Thiesel und Florian David Fitz, die eben dich und deine Frau darstellen. Und sind aber dann gleichzeitig diejenigen, die dem auch so ein bisschen die Schafe rausnehmen. Weil das sind ja so klassische Szenen, da wird einem ein bisschen enger ums Herz. Wenn jemand streitet, möchte man nicht dabei sein. Und wenn dann aber die beiden sich so einen Seitenblick geben, dann entlastet das so ein bisschen als Zusehender.
Ja, nein, also das war, wir hatten schnell Mut gefasst, nachdem klar war, auf wie offene Ohren wir stoßen insgesamt, dass wir so die, in den Drehbuchversionen 2, 3 und 4 auch nach und nach so ein bisschen an Oper und Ömchen so ein bisschen rumgeschraubt haben. Also, Oper war in einer Szene, jemand, wie er Fatemeh zurief, holen wir mal ein Bier oder irgendwie sowas, wo ich sagte, das passiert bei uns nicht, das ist völlig surreal. Also Bier schon mal gar nicht, wenn, dann muss es Malzbier sein bei uns. Und B, würde mein Vater nie meine Frau auffordern, so in der Form, sodass da ganz viel gemacht und angepasst wurde. Und es war dann irgendwann soweit, dass Richard, ich will nicht sagen genervt, aber gesagt hat, ja gut, ihr müsst mir dann schon helfen, ihr müsst mir dann Opa und Oma dann halt irgendwie auch schon beschreiben. Und Jason dann gesagt hat, du, wir machen das einfach, ich pack die und ich komm nach Berlin. Und dann haben die sich in Berlin getroffen und haben dort irgendwie so, ich weiß nicht, zwei, drei Stunden in einem Café verbracht. Und im Anschluss sagte Richard dann, okay, ich hab jetzt eine Idee, aber wir müssen auch nochmal drüber sprechen. Und ich sag, was ist denn los? Und er sagte, naja, wir haben dort gesessen und der Einzige, der gesprochen hat, war dein Dad. Und deine Mama saß dort und hat eigentlich kein Wort gesagt, weil sie gar nicht zu Wort kam, so richtig insgesamt. Und ja, dann haben wir dann gesagt, okay, dann ist das halt vielleicht auch so ein bisschen der Schwerpunkt für den Film, dass wir sagen, wir haben einen etwas präsenteren Opa. Und dann aber schon auch ein Ömchen, die in der Streitszene sehr geschickt nochmal kurz so dazwischen geht. Lasst euch nicht stören hier beim Streiten. Also das passt schon, das ist okay.
Aber das heißt, das hast du dann auf dich genommen, Jason? Denn das ist ja durchaus viel Aufwand, den ihr dann da alle betrieben habt.
Ja, also erstmal war mir das von Anfang an sehr wichtig. Und mir war ja auch von Anfang an, also von 2018, ehrlich gesagt, eigentlich schon in dem Moment, wo wir das Buch geschrieben haben, aber spätestens von 2018, war mir schon klar, dass es einen Film geben wird und dass der krass wird. Deswegen war ich auch von Anfang an bereit, sehr viel dort reinzustecken und viel Aufwand auf mich zu nehmen, weil ich damit gerechnet habe, dass es sich lohnt. Mir war auch klar, dass es dauern wird, bis es sich lohnt. Aber ich hatte so Geduld. Und dann muss man noch zweitens berücksichtigen, dass das für mich nicht wirklich Aufwand ist. Also so mit meinen Großeltern nach Berlin zu fahren und Richard zu treffen, das hat mir ja so Spaß gemacht. Und alles andere, was jetzt so kommt, und jetzt ist es ja noch mehr gerade, was mit dem Film zu tun hat, also dieses Ganze eigentlich durch Deutschland fahren und überall so Menschen eigentlich von deiner Geschichte erzählen, natürlich ist das irgendwie Aufwand und es schlaucht so körperlich, aber gleichzeitig waren so die letzten Monate, also ich glaube, das war eine der schönsten Zeiten überhaupt bis jetzt und es hat mir auch alles großen Spaß gemacht. Von daher ist es für mich nicht so anstrengend, wie alle Leute immer vermuten.
Das ist richtig schön. Sprecht ihr denn jetzt anders über eure Geschichte, weil wenn man drüber nachdenkt, ist das ja eigentlich schon seit mehreren Jahren euer Job, dass ihr durch Deutschland fahrt und auf verschiedene Art und Weise von eurer Geschichte erzählt. Was würdest du sagen, Jason, hat sich das jetzt verändert?
Wir können natürlich von immer mehr Dingen erzählen, weil unsere Geschichte ja weitergeht. Wir sind ja jetzt auch wieder nach Corona-Pause wieder in den Stadien und erleben dort weiter Dinge. Aber die Art und Weise, auf die wir darüber sprechen, würde ich sagen, hat sich nicht geändert. Wieso auch? Die Ereignisse in der Vergangenheit bleiben ja, die Ereignisse in der Vergangenheit, die ändern sich ja nicht mehr. Das heißt, es kommt immer nur mehr dazu. Aber die Art, auf die wir darüber sprechen, hat sich zumindest bei mir nicht verändert.
Würde ich so unterschreiben. Das Einzige, was sich so ganz aktuell so ein bisschen verändert, so aus diesen Interviews heraus, dass, wenn du den Einstieg hast oder du hast ein tieferes oder ein längeres Gespräch mit jemandem, dem du dann auch sagst, es ist schon sehr, sehr nah an der Realität alles, dass es dann halt trotzdem zu Fragen kommen kann und sagen, ja, okay, Jason war in der dritten Klasse in der Gefahr, in die Förderschule zu kommen. Nee, das war so nicht. Die Förderschule war eigentlich eher so dort. Also das Ganze chronologisch dann wieder so ein bisschen abzugleichen und zu ordnen, was ja eigentlich völlig irrsinnig ist, wenn du mit Leuten eigentlich über den Film sprechen willst oder so. Aber so dieses Setup, das ist manchmal ein bisschen ulkig. Aber ansonsten ist das eher, ja, so wie Jason sagt, es ist eher etwas, wo ich mich freue, dass es ihm so großen Spaß macht. Und ja, ich meine, auch Leo9 und Co. sind natürlich sehr, sehr happy, dass Florian hat es letzte Woche gesagt, er hat gesagt, er hat das so im Filmbusiness noch nicht erlebt, dass gerade so bei so autobiografischen Geschichten dann am Ende dann doch so ein Maß an Zufriedenheit herrscht oder so. Also es ist eigentlich eher sehr, sehr häufig etwas, wo man dann sagt, nee, also da gibt es jetzt schon diesen zumindest diesen einen schweren Punkt, dass ich mich damit nicht so ganz identifizieren kann oder so. Und das scheint relativ selten zu sein.
Ganz kurz, Leo9 und Co.?
Also wir haben quasi die Drehbuchrechte, hat sich Richard Kropf gesichert und hat dann quasi für die Produktion die Firma Leo9 bzw. Wiedemann & Berg mit ins Boot geholt, die dann ja all das gemacht haben, was dann so im Anschluss noch zu tun ist. Da gab es dann nach dem Drehbuch tatsächlich dann schon noch ein bisschen was, was dann so auch so die nächsten Meilensteine waren, die uns dann so verdeutlicht haben, wie groß das ganze Ding eigentlich wirklich wird.
Ja, da können wir später unter anderem über einen Cameo-Auftritt noch sprechen. Jetzt will ich aber unbedingt mal Aileen Thiesel zu Wort kommen lassen, denn so ein bisschen haben wir das Problem, was es auch im Film, du hast es schon thematisiert, gibt. Es ist ein Männer dominierter Film, weil ihr beide eben im Zentrum steht und so ein bisschen war das jetzt in dem Gespräch auch. Ich habe den Namen Florian David Fitt schon so oft gesagt, dass es ein Zungenbrecher für mich ist, weil er, weil du quasi in seiner Gestalt neben mir sitzt. Jetzt wollen wir mal unbedingt reinhören, was Aileen Thies gesagt hat, unter anderem zu ihrer Rolle, die sie gespielt hat, die ja dann deine Frau ist.
Es gibt keine Pause davon, dass man ununterbrochen jemand anderem versucht, das Leben zu vereinfachen oder überhaupt Lebenswert zu gestalten. Und das überhaupt zu schaffen, ich glaube, dafür muss man schon super stark sein. Ich hatte auch ein Telefonat mit der echten Fatime im Vorfeld und hatte auch das Gefühl, dass wirklich ihre Stärke auch aus einer Liebe herauskommt. Und für uns war das aber wichtig, dass wir Fatime jetzt nicht einfach, ich möchte das überhaupt nicht degradieren, aber jetzt nicht einfach nur als irgendwie, ja gut, die ist jetzt halt die Mama und Hausfrau, sondern ganz klar zeigen, was für eine unglaubliche Arbeit sie hat und dass sie ihrem Mann auch Grenzen aufzeigt, dass sie auch dann irgendwann sagt, okay, bis hier hin, aber jetzt kann ich nicht mehr und das übersteigt meine Kräfte. Und ich komme jetzt auch an einen Punkt, wo ich Angst habe, dadurch, dass ich nicht mehr kann, dass ich jetzt anfange, meinen Kindern dadurch Schaden zuzufügen, dass ich nicht genug für sie da sein kann und ich brauche jetzt deine Hilfe. Und das ist ja der Moment, wo der Film startet, dass sie eigentlich sagt, ja, du mein Mann bist draußen unterwegs und bringst das Geld nach Hause, aber du fehlst hier und ich brauche hier Unterstützung. Und so kommt es ja überhaupt erst, dass diese ganze Idee, mit dem der Vater soll sich mehr einbringen und dann die Idee, mit dem der Vater und der Sohn ziehen jetzt zusammen los und finden den Fußballverein. Das ist jetzt deren neues gemeinsames Hobby sozusagen. Dann hat Fatih mir auch zwischendurch mal irgendwie so einen Wochenendtag frei. Damit geht es eigentlich alles los.
Wie denkst du da drüber, also über das, was sie da gerade gesagt hat, im Bezug auf eine real existierende Beziehung? Und wie findest du, ist das im Film dargestellt?
Also es gibt, wenn wir fangen wir vielleicht, es ist immer ein bisschen schwierig mit der Spoilerei oder so, aber es gibt mehrere Szenen, aber es gibt eine, die ist so unfassbar eindrücklich. Da geht es darum, dass wir in der Schule vorsprechen müssen. Eigentlich wegen einem Anlass, an dem ich meistens gar nicht teilnehme, aber da die Schule quasi meine Präsenz tatsächlich mit einfordert. Und die ganze Mimik, das ganze Wording, es geht dann darum, dass Jason noch eine Chance bekommen soll. Und als wir die Szenen gesehen haben und dazu dann so auch die rechtszerzauste Eileen, die man sonst ja aus ihrem Instagram-Account dann doch auch eher kennt, so zurechtgemacht, wie sich das gehört. Aber so diese Film Eileen zu sehen, die so nah an Fatemeh dran ist, in diesem Setup, welches natürlich auch irgendwo eins zu eins aus unserem Leben entnommen ist, das ist halt unfassbar. Und das macht mich halt einerseits sehr, sehr glücklich, dass es schon auch jetzt im finalen Werk gelungen ist. Fatemes Stärken, also dieses kämpferische und dieses ja auch mir deutlich die Grenzen aufzeigen, zu sagen, so Freundchen, jetzt erzähl mir nicht noch 26 Mal, was du jetzt alles noch kurz zu erledigen hast, jetzt brauche ich dich hier. Da ist von der Auswahl erstmal natürlich, ich meine, die beiden waren letzte Woche, das ist alles so skurril, als die letzte Woche auf der Premiere waren, auf der Publikumsprämie in Essen, sind wir so nach vorne über den Teppich gegangen und ich hätte fast Eileen Tetzel den Namen genommen, weil sie direkt neben mir lief und plötzlich Fateme weg war und ich habe gesagt, Mensch, das tut mir total leid, und sie hat gesagt, ja, alles gut, das passiert, um ihr fünf Minuten später, als wir uns vorne hinsetzen wollten, zum Sito wiederum zu sagen, komm, setz dich zur Mama, ich meine, das ist ja gar nicht seine Mama, also sie hat das anscheinend dann doch recht überzeugend gut gemacht oder mir gelingt diese Trennung noch nicht so wahnsinnig gut, Aber wir sind, für mich ist das, was Jason vorhin auch sagte so ein bisschen, Sito ist der, der die absolute Punktlandung gemacht hat, wo ich wirklich sage, mir fällt es schwer, die beiden in sich ihrer G-Stick, Mimik, so ganz vielen Aspekten auseinanderzuhalten. Das ist aber mindestens genauso gut Eileen irgendwo gelungen und das eigentlich ohne, dass es Begleitmaterial oder Zugang irgendwie zur Terabyte von Dropbox-Daten oder sonstiges gab, sondern die haben halt einfach lange telefoniert. Fateme hat so ein bisschen gesagt, was ihr wichtigst und dann hat das einfach komplett gut gepasst. Und sowohl Fateme findet sich dort wieder und auch Eileen ist sehr, sehr glücklich. Als sie sich dann letzte Woche auch dann beide endlich final mal kennenlernen konnten, hatte ich wirklich den Eindruck, dass es auch ihr wichtig war, so nach dem Telefonat, dass sie sagte dann, aber gleich lerne ich Fateme kennen und ist die denn wirklich zufrieden? Ich sage ja, Eileen, diese wirklich 100, es ist absolut. Na, aber ich will es schon noch mal von ihr selber hören. Wann lerne ich die denn endlich kennen? Ich so, ja, sie kommt ja heute, alles gut, beruhigt euch mal so ein bisschen. Also es war sehr, sehr schön anzusehen, dass das Art diesen sehr pragmatischen Prozess, ein Telefonat, ich spiele es, es klappt, es ist perfekt, während die Männer es wieder ein Riesenprohaid rummachen, was wie wo zu machen ist und so weiter. Sehr, sehr schön, sehr, sehr schön, macht uns sehr, sehr glücklich.
Aber sie hätte ja genauso viel mitreden dürfen, wie ihr das gemacht habt bei ihrer Besetzung und so weiter und so fort.
Also Fatemehr hat wohl mit auf den Weg gegeben, ich sah da schon anders aus, als man sich jetzt vorstellt, also schon recht zerstört und so weiter. Und das hat Eileen 1 zu 1 angenommen. Und wenn da was gewesen wäre, dann hätten wir da sicherlich auch noch reagieren können. Aber das war tatsächlich bei Erliegen 0,0 notwendig.
Man hat ja auch so ein bisschen das Gefühl, Andreas, im Film gehabt, die ersten, ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr, 10, 15 Minuten ist jetzt, wir haben ihn im Juli gesehen, deswegen für uns ist jetzt ein bisschen lang her. Aber das ist so die Startrampe für ja dann eure gemeinsame Reise, muss ja auch so sein. Und da ist aber eigentlich eben Fatima bzw. Eileen dann diejenige, die da quasi die Zündung startet und die vorher auch, womit wenigen Szenen klargemacht wird, wie der Alltag für sie auch aussieht.
Ich fand da diese eine Szene wirklich beeindruckend, wo es gegenübergestellt worden ist, das Frühstück zu Hause und das Frühstück von Mirco an irgendeiner Raststätte bzw. in irgendeinem Hotel, wo er so ein bisschen mit seinem Essen geast hat. Und zu Hause wurden halt die Essenskomponenten getrennt voneinander aufgestellt. Und da wurde für mich dann auch in den ersten 15 Minuten ersichtlich und finde, das macht der Film extrem gut, wie schwer diese Kehrarbeit dann auch ist und wie unterschätzt das vielleicht dann auch ist. Und das fand ich, dass das erst mal so ein bisschen als Pflok eingerammt worden ist. Das ist die Situation und die ist verdammt, verdammt schwierig für die Mutter im Moment gerade. Und sie ist auch schwierig für Jason, aber die Mutter wird hier dargestellt, als die, die hier einen echt extremen Job macht, verlustiert sich in Anführungsstrichen so ein bisschen dann im Hotel, wo er auf seinen Reisen ist und die Mutter hat einen wirklich harten Job. Und es ist am Ende ihrer Kräfte. Und das, finde ich, hat der Film ganz hervorragend gemacht, wirklich in diesen ersten 15 Minuten im Vlog eingerammt.
Ich sehe hier viel Nicken neben mir. Das ist ja quasi so die erste Aufgabe dieses Films gewesen, die Charaktere und Persönlichkeiten abzubieten. Und dann kommen wir abzubilden, Entschuldigung. Und dann kommen wir zu der zweiten, vielleicht noch größeren Aufgabe. Ihr habt es ja auch schon so besprochen, die Darstellung von Autismus Extrem. Wichtiges Thema, weil man ja auch da einen Flock einrannt, so wie du es gerade gesagt hast, in anderem Bezug. Weil wir eben einfach wissen, diesen Film werden hoffentlich sehr, sehr viele Menschen sehen und die werden ihr Bild über Autismus sicherlich verändern. Und da möchte man es natürlich in die richtige Art und Weise verändern. Und auch darüber hat natürlich Andreas mit Florian David Fitz und Aileen Thies gesprochen. Und vielleicht hören wir mal rein, was Aline dazu gesagt hat und nehmen das zum Anlass, darüber noch mal ein bisschen zu sprechen.
Und dann einfach sich mal dessen bewusst zu werden, wie hypersensibel so die Wahrnehmung von Menschen auf dem Spektrum funktioniert. Und dann kommt natürlich noch dazu, dass man gewisse Routinen braucht, dass man gewisse Regeln braucht, um überhaupt nur den Alltag durchzustehen, ohne eine hohe Nervosität zu haben oder auch ein bisschen Panikausbrüchen zu bekommen. Ich spreche jetzt vor allem von dem Autismus, den wir in unserem Film erzählen, den der junge Jason hat. Es gibt halt, wie gesagt, deswegen heißt es ja auch Spektrum, es ist natürlich ein Riesenspektrum mit den unterschiedlichsten Ausführungen. Deswegen, ich bin da jetzt auch kein Experte. Ich habe mich jetzt auch nur für den Film einfach damit beschäftigt und so erste Erfahrungen sammeln können. Aber ich habe auch während des Films und auch nach dem Film weiter gelernt. Also ich lerne weiterhin darüber.
Lass uns mal darüber ein bisschen sprechen. Jason, ich finde, die erste Frage muss da eigentlich an dich gehen. Du hast schon angedeutet, dass du zufrieden bist mit der Darstellung deines Autismus im Film. Was war da besonders wichtig zu beachten?
Besonders wichtig zu beachten war, dass erstens nicht der Eindruck entsteht, der Autismus würde auf unseren Reisen irgendwie verschwinden oder nachlassen oder irgendwie weniger werden oder gar geheilt werden durch unsere Reisen. Und zum Start sind dann plötzlich die Dinge, die ansonsten immer nicht erträglich sind, plötzlich einfach erträglich werden und überhaupt nicht mehr stören. Der Eindruck durfte auf gar keinen Fall entstehen. Wir haben tatsächlich, um das wirklich zu 100 Prozent sicherzustellen, um gar keine Missverständnisse aufkommen zu lassen, haben wir sogar das Ende tatsächlich nochmal abgeändert während des Prozesses. Also da lag eine ganz hohe Priorität drauf. Und dann natürlich darauf, dass die Verhaltensweisen, die von mir so gezeigt werden, nicht ins Lächerliche gezogen werden, auch versehentlich vielleicht, wofür eigentlich Sito schon gesorgt hat auf die Art, auf die er das gespielt hat. Und dann ging es natürlich noch um das Wording praktisch, also um die Formulierung, dass ich Autist bin, nicht Autismus habe, oder dass nicht von Asperger-Syndrom gesprochen wird, außer in der Diagnosis-Szene, wo das Ganze leider noch verwendet wurde. Auch von offizieller Seite, wo der Begriff ja mittlerweile veraltet ist. Und da ging es wirklich sehr weit ins Detail. Das war der Punkt, wo ich mit Abstand am Penibelsen war, sage ich mal in Anführungszeichen.
Und gleichzeitig ist da dann die Herausforderung. Und das wird aber auch versucht darzustellen. Ich fand es interessant, dass Aldine Thies das jetzt gerade im O-Ton auch so sagt, Mirco. Es ist eben ein Spektrum. Und das, was wir hier sehen, ist nur ein, es ist jetzt quasi die Ausprägung, wie ihr sie erlebt und wie du sie hast. Aber es ist halt nicht gemeingültig. Und dennoch möchte man ja allgemein für ein Bewusstsein schaffen und für ein Verständnis sorgen durch so etwas. Aber wie kann man so etwas begegnen? Ich denke, über diese Frage werdet ihr wahrscheinlich nächtelang diskutiert haben.
Ja, wobei, also wenn du dann einen Gegenüber hast, der zuhört, es dann ja auch gar nicht so kompliziert ist manchmal. Also ich bin ja auch kein Autismus-Experte. Ich kenne ja auch nur das, was ich kenne, Jason, mit seiner Persönlichkeit und habe eine Ahnung, wann, wo vielleicht ein Symptom oder ein Merkmal durchsticht. Aber es war natürlich auch schon mal super hilfreich, wenn du dann jemanden wie jetzt auch in dem Fall Aileen, die, ich habe die letzte Woche ihr das auch gesagt, sie hat in sämtlichen Interviewreihen so respektvoll, vorsichtig und aufmerksamkeit auch dieses Thema behandelt, während es ja schon dann auch mal Situationen gibt, wo jemand, gerade im Kontext Autismus, sehr schnell, also uns ist es selber schon passiert, wir haben mal eine Doku gemacht mit jemandem, waren super vorsichtig, am Ende hieß die Doku aus dem Glaskasten oder irgend so was. Also da passte der Titel nicht. Die Doku ist wirklich total super, aber der Titel hat uns halt wahnsinnig gejagert. Und auch im Film gibt es ja so mit diesem Aufzugmoment und dem Ausspruch vom Vater, sprich von Florian, er wird immer in seinem Aufzug fahren. Das war tatsächlich eine der Szenen, die nicht im Drehbuch-Final standen, dann so noch so dazukamen und wo es auch schon noch mal Diskussionen gab, die nicht jeder verstanden hat am Anfang. Also natürlich verstehe ich diesen Aspekt mit, ich muss mich auf ihn einlassen, wenn man es so interpretiert, aber es kann natürlich auch schnell aufzugreifen, ah ja, diese geschlossene autistische Welt oder sowas. Das war eine Sorge, die wir früher hatten, wo uns dann gesagt wurde, hey, macht euch keine Sorgen, wenn ihr den Film in Gänze seht, dann seht ihr, dass das Ganze auch anders transportiert wird und von daher ist das fine. Aber wir haben sehr früh darauf geachtet oder auch mit Richard uns schon abgestimmt, haben gesagt, okay, du wirst ja nicht den CITUNA-Autismus-Schulung unterziehen können und du wirst auch nicht die Situation haben können, dass der sechs Wochen mit Jason zusammenlebt oder irgendwas, sodass wir dann auf die Erfahrungswerte zurückgegriffen haben, die wir nutzen konnten. Das heißt als erstes, bitte nicht googeln nach Autismus. Du landest in neun von zehn Fällen auf der falschen Seite. Wir haben mit autismuskultur.de eine Webseite angeboten, wo wir wissen, da kommt wirklich die autistische Perspektive, steht dort im Fokus. Und haben mit der Schattenspringer-Reihe, das ist ein Comic von Daniela Schreiter, die auch Autistin ist und mittlerweile vier oder fünf Comics über ihr Leben dargestellt hat, einen total niedrigschwelligen Einstieg. Also ich lese auch keine Fachbücher über Autismus, weil ich das nicht verstehe. Das ist dann eher vielleicht mal Jasons Part. Und all diese unterstützten Hilfsmittel haben zumindest für so ein Grundverständnis gesorgt. Und wir haben dann nach und nach immer wieder Materialien zur Verfügung gestellt. Oder halt Jason aus seiner Perspektive selbst, per Videopodcast, was auch immer versucht, so ein bisschen darzustellen, was ist wichtig und wo sind so diese Unterschiede. Und das hat dann gut geklappt. Wir mussten bei ein paar Sachen so im Post-Production-Prozess noch mal so ein bisschen agieren, weil einfach kleinere Wording-Sachen drin waren. Gerade so diese Diagnoseszene am Anfang war da nicht so ganz einfach.
Weil ja auch die Diagnose im echten Leben nicht optimal verlief.
Ja, und erstens das und zweitens gab es eigentlich eine Vermischung von zwei Situationen. Denn wir haben nicht nur ein Diagnosegespräch, wir hatten eigentlich zwei Diagnosegespräche, weil wir haben zu dem Zeitpunkt noch hier in München gelebt. Und der Erstkontakt war mit jemanden von der Caritas, die Jason begleitet hat im Kindergarten etc. und die gesagt hat, ich gehe davon aus, dass ihr Sohn Aspergerhaut ist, ich darf aber gar nicht diagnostizieren. Und wir haben dann Kontakt aufgenommen zum Hexer Klinikum hier in München, die die Diagnostik machen. Gut, das ist aber dann halt, da vergehen halt erst mal sechs Monate. Also das ist jetzt nicht so, dass du eine Woche später dahingehst und dann sagst du ja, alles klar, das passt so, sondern das war sechs Monate. Und diese beiden Gespräche waren sehr unterschiedlich. Das Caritas-Gespräch war sehr einfühlsam und vorsichtig und sehr empathisch, während das Diagnosgespräch schon sehr bar und sehr hart war. Und nach der dritten Nachfrage dann irgendwo so endete mit, sie werden sich damit abfinden müssen, dass ihr Sohn behindert ist. Und es viele Dinge gibt, die er nicht schaffen kann. Und meine Frau fragte dann ja, was bedeutet das schulisch so? Ja gut, der wird wahrscheinlich auf eine Förderschule gehen insgesamt. Also das war schon sehr barsch und sehr, sehr absolut irgendwie, wie das dann auch von einem Experten entgegengebracht wird. Und das war natürlich auch etwas, was wir nie vergessen haben und auch gerne in den Film transportiert hätten, sodass Jason eigentlich so die Vorgabe gemacht hat und sagt, es muss mit rein, dass Autismus nicht heilbar ist, weil das immer wieder ein Thema ist. Es muss mit rein, dass es ein Spektrum ist. Und so haben die dann diese Diagnoseszene et cetera so gebaut, dass das dann so ein Mix aus beiden ist und einigermaßen klar ist, was los ist.
Also quasi möglichst nah an der Realität, aber noch mit einem pädagogischen Auftrag.
Ja, das war der Wunsch, dem auch nachgekommen wurde und der wirklich gut gelungen ist.
Andreas, darüber haben wir ja auch gesprochen, viel nach dem Film, weil das logischerweise auch etwas ist, wo sowas sehr schnell kippen kann. Und da werden verschiedene Techniken angewandt, ohne dass ich da jetzt spoilere. Da gibt es Montagen, es gibt natürlich Tonkulissen, die verwendet werden, schnelle Schnitte hintereinander. Uns beide hat das sehr bewegt, glaube ich. Also wir sind nicht neutral aus diesem Film herausgegangen, so sehr wir uns darüber gefreut haben, deine Pullover und deine Jacke wieder zu erkennen. Und auch Jason, es war irgendwie toll, dich nochmal in Jung zu erleben. Aber das war für uns auch ein wichtiges Thema. Was ist dir davon noch in Erinnerung geblieben? Und wie bist du jetzt auch, ich meine, wir haben es jetzt vor einer ganzen Weile schon gesehen im Nachhinein mit der Darstellung, ja zufrieden ist das falsche Wort, aber was hat es bei dir hinterlassen?
Na also bei mir hat es dann, ich kann das halt wirklich jetzt nur als Zuschauer nachvollziehen bzw. kann das nur darstellen, aber mich hat es sehr zufrieden zurückgelassen. Ich habe ja in den Jahren, wo ich das Blog schon verfolgt habe und wo ich dann auch Mirco kennen gelernt habe und auch Jason kennen gelernt habe, habe ich ja schon sehr viel über Autismus gelernt. Ich habe eben noch mal nachgeguckt, während ihr gesprochen habt, Autismus in Filmen, wie er behandelt worden ist bzw. wie ich ihn dann schon mal gesehen habe, berühmtester Film, vielleicht dann auch Rain Man und so. Aber diese ganze Geschichte rundum, das ist ein Spektrum und das sind verschiedene Ausprägungen. Da habe ich lange gebraucht, um das dann auch zu lernen. Das habe ich dann über den Podcast über das Blog und dann auch über das Buch kennengelernt. Und das sollte dann mit Nachdruck nochmal gebracht werden. Erstens, das ist keine Clowns-Veranstaltung hier, sondern das ist jetzt nicht der Guckenweih in irgendeiner Weise witzig drüber, sondern wir wollen das möglichst ernsthaft drüber bringen, sodass dann auch wirklich alle es verstehen. Und dass das dann wirklich eine Ausprägung ist und dass es dann ein Spektrum ist. Und das, finde ich, hat dieser Film extrem gut rübergebracht. Und ich finde auch, dass er das mit Nachdruck rübergebracht hat, weil ja diese Erklärungsszene dann am Anfang ist, mit diesem Gespräch dann auch. Und da habe ich das Kino dann auch wieder sehr zufrieden verlassen, weil das, was ich gelernt habe über die Jahre, ist dann ja auch nochmal kurz runtergedampft auf ein paar Minuten, ist das sehr gut rübergebracht worden. Und dass gleich so ein bisschen der Wind aus den Segeln genommen wird, das ist hier keine Komödie. Und dann wird es nicht auf die Schippe genommen, sondern das ist hier ein ernsthaftes Thema. Und das wird so ernsthaft wie möglich und so seriös wie möglich angegangen.
Das ist ein sehr wahrhaftiger Anspruch, den der Film an die Realität und an seine Geschichte hat. Das war auch so mein Eindruck. Und dazu gehört hier auch die Art und Weise, wie sowohl dann du im, also dein Film, ich, mit dieser Situation umgeht und natürlich auch die ganze Reise. Wir wollen jetzt hier nicht spoilern, aber das ist auch nochmal eine interessante Frage gewesen, die du, Floy, an David Fitts gestellt hast, an Andreas, was man denn dann mitnimmt aus einem solchen Film. Und da fand ich seine Antwort sehr interessant.
Ich weiß nicht, ob Mirco dir wirklich ein Learning geben kann. Also vieles auch einfach tatsächlich aushalten. Weil, na klar, die Leute im Bordrestaurant, oft genug passiert es hier, dass einfach verzogene Kinder rumschreien, die Eltern rumschicken und du sagst natürlich, Alter, was ist los? Ja, ist genau wie du sagst. Wenn dann jemand sagt, übrigens hier ist die Diagnose, das ist bitte kurz Verständnis, dann ist es was anderes. Also man muss natürlich auch die anderen Leute verstehen, weil man wäre selber ja wahrscheinlich eher auf der Seite der Leute im Bräutbestro, dass man sagt, weil man hat es ja ein paar Mal erlebt und man hat nicht jedes Mal so reagiert, vielleicht ist er ja auf dem Spektrum und deswegen hat er, also das ist nicht das erste, was du denkst und dass eine Mutter dann zu dir sagt, mein Kind ist übrigens, bla bla bla, xy, na klar, ihr Kind ist alles, was sie wollen, weißt du? Es ist so simpel ist es nicht, es ist einfach auch unfassbar nervig. Insofern glaube ich, es gibt diese einfache Handhabe nicht. Ich verstehe auch die Leute und Mirco ist der Letzte, der die Leute nicht versteht, weil er sagt, es gab Momente, wo er ihn einfach erwürgen will und ich glaube auch das muss man sich zugestehen, sonst laufen alle so pärzlich und heilig und humorlos rum. Ich glaube, die einzige Waffe und das macht Mirco halt super, ist auch Humor, damit umzugehen. Das ist einfach mal kacke, es ist missverständlich, es ist mühsam, es ist super peinlich, wenn dein Kind dir da so rum ins Essen spuckt und sagt, da frisst meine Reste und du bist so ja, natürlich Meister, ich esse die Reste, damit es hier jetzt keinen Aufstand gibt. Das ist halt kacke, aber es ist auch sehr interessant und was du sagst ist ja, Mirco hat es ja geschafft, durch diesen Humor und durch diese Story mit den Vereinen, die Leute dafür zu interessieren, sich in dieses Leben mal rein zu begeben. Und das ist einfach spannend, mehr muss es auch gar nicht sein.
Mehr muss es vielleicht gar nicht sein, Mirco.
Klingt ganz einfach eigentlich, ne?
Dafür hat er eine Minute gebraucht, wenn man so den Podcast machen sollte.
Nein, hat er recht, hat er aber auch gut zusammengefasst in vielen Bereichen. Ja, nein, absolut, das passt. Es ist halt immer nicht so ganz einfach, auf Basis von einzelnen Szenen dort die große Geschichte aufzumachen, aber Florian hat das sehr schnell geschafft, mir zu erklären, wie er die Situation oder wie er seine Mirco-Perspektive so wahrnimmt. Okay, du bist so dieser berufliche Problemlöser dort und willst da alles regeln und musst da alles regeln und zu Hause gibt es immer eine Situation, die kriegst du nicht so richtig geregelt und das passte, das war fein und hat das gut zusammengefasst.
Und Jason, wie denkst du darüber, wenn du das hörst, weil da ja auch, da haben wir schon mal indirekt im Tribünengespräch damals auch schon darüber gesprochen, immer wieder in den Texten, die erst im Blog erschienen sind und dann im Buch, wurde ja auch dadurch, dass Mirco das humorvoll verarbeitet hat, aber auch sehr ehrlich, da sind auch manchmal harte Sätze über dich gefallen und hier war er jetzt auch gerade, am liebsten hätte er ihn manchmal erwirkt, also natürlich nicht physisch, sondern im übertragenen Sinn. Aber wie ist das für dich, wenn du das so hörst?
Naja, ich widerspreche da natürlich an manchen Stellen, so was ich das anders sehe. Ich bin auch der Meinung, man kann von meinen Mitmenschen abverlangen, dass sie sich kein vorschnelles Urteil bilden, sondern selbst wenn sie nicht wissen, dass ich auf dem Spektrum bin, kann man grundsätzlich allen Menschen mit der Einstellung begegnen, dass man es ja nicht weiß, dass man die Ursache für das, was man dort gerade erlebt, ja nicht kennt und deswegen keine voreiligen Schlüsse zieht. Das ist nicht die Realität, das weiß ich ja selber, aber ich finde, das kann man durchaus von Menschen verlangen, deswegen kann man auch das Verhalten von diesen Menschen im Broadbistro oder an der Bushaltestelle kritisieren, meiner Meinung nach. Also die verhalten sich falsch, aber es ist ja trotzdem in der Realität so. So reagieren halt die meisten Menschen und ja, das mag dann so sein. Ich kann Papst ja nicht in seiner Wahrnehmung widersprechen. Für ihn war das dann so, für ihn war das dann peinlich vielleicht oder unangenehm auf jeden Fall. Ich sehe da nirgendswo meine Schuld, aber das hat er dann ja auch in der Regel nicht geschrieben. Also klar, an manchen Stellen sind wir uns auch uneinig über die Schuldfrage, aber wir sind uns eher selten uneinig über die Schuldfrage, sondern meistens sind es einfach halt unangenehme Situationen, die für Papst die unangenehm sind, an denen ich dann aber auch leider nichts ändern kann und dementsprechend fühle ich mich da auch nicht verantwortlich.
Ich glaube, da muss man aber auch so ein bisschen zwei Perspektiven unterscheiden. Einmal die Perspektive so auf unser Umfeld, wenn wir untereinander unterwegs sind, also wenn wir jetzt die Bord-Bistro-Szene als Beispiel nehmen, dann ist mir das natürlich unangenehm so, wenn du da so, also das wird sich auch nicht ändern lassen. Ich kann aber nachvollziehen, dass das für dich nicht so ist.
Mir war die auch unangenehm tatsächlich.
Okay. Was aber eine zweite Perspektive ist, ist so dieser Umgang von uns beiden miteinander auch so in seiner, in der Härte, die wir manchmal pflegen. Und ich glaube da, das wäre so die zweite Szene, wo Florian und ich auch so ein bisschen, ich will nicht sagen unterschiedlicher Meinung war. Doch, will ich sagen, wir waren da unterschiedlicher Meinung. Das ist, wo ich an einer Stelle zu Jason sage, also im Film zu Jason sage, dass mir die Arbeit wichtiger ist als er. Und das eigentlich aus einer wirklich auch mit einem kurzen Moment des Überlegens, also nicht so rein aus dem Effekt. Okay, ja, in der Szene geht es ihm auch gerade nicht so ganz gut. Er hat da eine harte Zeit hinter sich. Aber das ist so der, so ein bisschen das, wo sich vielleicht zwischen Real-Wochenend-Rebellen und Film-Wochenend-Rebellen auch so ein bisschen aus unterschiedlichsten Gründen die Wege trennen. Wenn es bei uns zwischen uns eskaliert, dann ist das etwas, wo auch die Überforderung von beiden Seiten irgendwie so der Auslöser des ganzen ist. Denn es wird dann sehr, sehr barisch, sehr, sehr hart manchmal. Und da fallen dann auch Worte, die zum Glück, egal von wem sie kommen, auch kurze Zeit später wieder vergessen sind. Aber es ist nicht so dieses Kurz-Überlegen und dann so, ja eigentlich finde ich dich ganz schön scheiße. Das kam so in der Form nie vor und auch nicht, dass es eine Situation gab, wo ich auch nur eine Sekunde darüber nachgedacht habe, ob mir meine Arbeit tatsächlich wichtiger ist als mein Sohn. Es ist im Film natürlich so dieses, und das kann ich wieder nachvollziehen, und das will ich auch gar nicht ganz von der Hand weisen, diese Flucht in die Arbeit manchmal so, dass die natürlich damit so ein bisschen gestärkt werden soll, die sicherlich auch mal da war, die aber sicherlich in unserem realen Leben nicht so der Hauptantrieb des Ganzen war. Das sind glaube ich so diese beiden Blickwinkel, die sich da irgendwo vereinen.
Jason, weil du es eben gesagt hast, die Boardbistro-Szene, die war dir auch unangenehm. Gibt es Situationen dann heute noch, du hast Regeln aufgestellt oder ihr habt Regeln aufgestellt, dann ja auch in der Familie, gibt es Situationen dann heute noch, wo du sagst, das ist mir jetzt unangenehm, aber wir müssen da jetzt durch? Oder sind diese Regeln jetzt so fest installiert, dass du sagst, das ist halt so jetzt und für wen es unangenehm ist, ist mir egal, das machen wir jetzt so? Oder gibt es wirklich dann auch Szenen im täglichen Leben, die dir dann auch noch unangenehm sind?
Ach so, nicht, dass dann ein Missverständnis auftaucht. Mir war die Boardbistro-Szene nicht unangenehm, weil sie in der Öffentlichkeit stattfand. Mir war die Boardbistro-Szene unangenehm aus offensichtlichen Gründen, weil das Problem nicht gelöst werden konnte, weil das Essen am Ende verschwendet wurde. Also das Problem wäre für mich nicht größer gewesen, wenn es bei uns im Wohnzimmer stattgefunden hätte. Und es haben auch vergleichbare Situationen mit uns im Wohnzimmer stattgefunden. Aber nein, es gibt nichts, also es gibt eigentlich keine Situationen oder Eskalationen so, wo ich mich sage, da schäne ich mich für uns der Öffentlichkeit gegenüber, weil wir da total eskalieren oder so, sondern es hat dann halt auch seine Gründe. Und ich, wie gesagt, die Bordmistros-Szenen zum Beispiel, dafür könnte ich mir, also ich kann es sowieso nicht, aber es wäre auch total unsinnig, dafür irgendwie meinen Vorwurf zu machen, weil diese Szene vorbestimmt war, ja. Es konnte in dem Moment, wo diese Nudeln mit der Soße drauf kamen, war diese gesamte Situation vorbestimmt. Es konnte gar nichts anderes mehr passieren als diese Eskalation, weil durch die faktischen Bedingungen eigentlich alles bereits determiniert war. Und so ist das häufig. Und die Regeln, die wir heute haben, hinter den Regeln stehe ich ja auch. Ich meine, wir haben die Familienvereinbarung zu Hause, die ja im Film auch gezeigt wird, aber deutlich, deutlich vereinfacht der Realität gegenüber. Also die reale Familienvereinbarung ist erstens strenger. Auch die Regel, dass kein Essen entsorgt wird, diese Ausnahmen, die da gestellt werden, die gibt es so gar nicht. Also die Regeln sind viel strenger, als sie im Film gezeigt werden teilweise. Und komplexer. Aber hinter den Regeln stehe ich auch. Und sie auch dann in der Öffentlichkeit zu vertreten und in der Öffentlichkeit auch umzusetzen. Das ist ja erstens meine verfassungsmäßige Pflicht als Vorsitzender, der ich auch nachkommen muss.
Du bist Vorsitzender des Familienrats? War das das letzte Mal auch schon, seit wir vor vielen Jahren gekommen sind?
Ich hatte mich zwar...
Nee, einmal in Jahren wird gewählt.
Ich hatte mich zwar beim letzten Mal auch zur Wahl gestellt, aber...
Genau richtig, du hast dann deine Schäster für dich gewinnen können.
Und dementsprechend muss ich diese Regeln natürlich auch umsetzen, aber ich will sie auch umsetzen. Und nein, es ist mir nicht unangenehm, sie umzusetzen, auch in der Öffentlichkeit nicht, sondern die sind so.
Eine Sache noch zum Bordbistro. Wenn die Leute, die im Bordbistro mit euch dort drin saßen damals, wenn die diesen Film sehen, sie werden ganz genau wissen, wo sie zu dem Zeitpunkt waren, als die Bordbistro-Szene entstand. Weil das ist eine Szene, die, wenn ich sie im Bordbistro erlebt hätte, die ich bis ans Ende meiner Tage erzählen würde. Und da bin ich mir sicher, da werden zwei oder drei Menschen, die im Bordbistro damals saßen, die werden in diesem Film sitzen, vielleicht und denken, Moment, Moment, Moment, das bin ja ich.
Das ist sehr gut möglich, ja. Wir haben jetzt, glaube ich, in den letzten zehn Tagen schon 15 Anfragen vom VfR am bekommen. Aus unterschiedlichsten Gründen. Fanverein, der größte Blog, ich bin Anhänger, ich bin seit 30 Jahren dort. Von daher kann gut sein, dass auch da noch über die Kinoebene noch was passiert.
Aber hat sich Jimbo's Autowäsche auch gemeldet?
Die haben sich tatsächlich noch nicht gemeldet. Und da ist es sogar noch skurriler. Die haben wir nämlich sogar mal aktiv angeschrieben, weil wir dort eigentlich gerne auf der Lesereise unsere letzte Benefizlesung machen wollten. So einfach so vor dieser Autowäsche. Aber die haben sich tatsächlich nicht gemeldet.
Wahrscheinlich dachten wir, es wäre ein Scherz.
Ja, das könnte sein.
Da kennen sie euch schlecht, kann man dazu nur sagen. Aber wie ist denn das, wenn man so an einem Drehbuch arbeitet und quasi an der Fiktionalisierung der eigenen Charaktere arbeitet und dann eben auch solche Streitszenen zum Beispiel hat? Jason, denkst du jetzt manchmal anders über Konflikte, die ihr miteinander habt, weil du diese Außenperspektive jetzt ja viel häufiger einnehmen musstest in den letzten Monaten?
Ja, also über meine Reaktion denke ich eigentlich nicht anders. Aber mir ist dann schon klar, dass, wenn man diesen Streit dann mal nüchtern analysiert, ist mir natürlich auch klar, dass man nicht in allen Situationen Papsi die Schuld trägt. Was? Ja.
Was ist denn mit dir los?
Wir haben gerade einen der schönsten Momente in deinem Leben.
Jetzt habe ich mehr Gänsehaut als bei der Kinofremiere. Wirklich?
Also bei der Nudelszene zum Beispiel. Das war einfach eine Situation, die war durch die Fakten, so wie sie waren, so vorbestimmt. Da hätte niemand von uns irgendwas dran ändern können. Dass Papsi mich dann dort raussehrt, war natürlich die schlechteste mögliche Reaktion von allen. Aber selbst eine beste Reaktion hätte die Eskalation nicht verhindern können. Also insofern kann man, wenn man diese Streitsituation dann nüchtern analysiert, dann fällt es natürlich viel leichter zu sehen, okay, da hätte niemand was anderes machen können oder da trägt genau, da trägt die Person die Schuld. Da sind es die Fakten, die das einfach so vorbestimmt haben. Also da lassen sich die Streit natürlich noch mal anders analysieren. Aber rückwirkend gab es jetzt auch keinen Streit, den ich mir dann rückblickend angeguckt habe, wo ich sage, ja, also der war eigentlich, den hätte man so vermeiden können. Der war komplett unsinnig, da habe ich überreagiert oder so. Das kann ich rückblickend eigentlich nicht erkennen. Also ja, man blickt auf viele Streits noch mal anders. Aber ich denke, die Streitsituationen hatten in der Regel auch meinerseits aus einem guten Grund. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass ich einfach diese Szenen, die dort im Film gezeigt werden, sind ja keine Wutausbrüche. Ich glaube, es wird kein einziger klassischer Wutausbruch gezeigt, die es ja auch gibt. Also einfach Wutausbrüche, Situationen, in denen ich irgendwie meinen Willen nicht bekomme und dann halt meine Umgebung bestrafe, indem ich halt ausraste. Und dann muss man irgendwie nachgeben oder verhandeln, um das zu beenden. Das gibt es ja auch, aber das wird im Film eigentlich nicht gezeigt. Sondern die Eskalationen, wenn ich mich jetzt nicht komplett irre, also eigentlich alle, die im Film gezeigt werden, sind wirklich Overloads. Und die haben immer einen guten Grund. Also die haben immer, die geschehen nicht von alleine, sondern die geschehen, weil sich irgendwas in der Umgebung so verhält, dass ich damit nicht zurechtkomme, dass ich damit nicht klarkomme und dass ich davon befordert werde. Und dementsprechend kann auch ich dort für diese Situation nichts. Es ist nicht so, dass ich diese Eskalationen bewusst eingesetzt habe, um einen Willen zu bekommen. Ich habe auch immer bewusst Eskalationen eingesetzt, um einen Willen zu bekommen, aber nicht in diesen Situationen.
Aber es ist ja eigentlich dann auch eine Stärke, was du eben gesagt hast, wenn man die Situation und den Streit nüchtern analysiert. Gelingt ja auch nicht jedem, einen Streit anschließend nüchtern zu analysieren, beziehungsweise braucht es dann ja auch so ein bisschen. Und ist das dann vielleicht auch so eine Stärke, dass wenn man die Konflikte hat und wenn man, ihr habt es erzählt, dass es zwischendurch richtig kracht, dass man dann irgendwann dann auch in die nüchternen Analyse gehen kann? Weil, das kann ich von mir aus zugeben, das gelingt mir nicht immer bei Streitereien mit Familienmitgliedern, in die nüchternen Analyse zu gehen.
Das geht bei uns eigentlich immer relativ schnell. Also manchmal noch am selben Tag bei so kleineren Sachen, würde ich sagen. Wobei kleinere Sachen nicht heißen, dass die Streit weniger intensiv sind, sondern dass die Ursache eigentlich Kleinigkeiten waren. Und der Streit hauptsächlich dadurch eskalieren konnte, dass einer von uns halt eine extrem kurze Zündschnur hatte. Oder manchmal auch beide gleichzeitig. Also ich sag mal, letztes Jahr hat es ausgereicht, dass ich in einem rumänischen Zug nicht rechtzeitig zur Seite gegangen bin, als jemand kam. Dass Papsi mich mit übelsten Schimpfwörtern, also FSK 18 Schimpfwörtern, durch diesen ganzen Zug gebrüllt hat. Zum Glück war es ein rumänischer Zug und kein ICE, so dass die Leute uns nicht verstanden haben. Solche Streit sind schnell analysiert, weil es relativ einfache Situationen sind. Da war die Schuldfrage so leicht zu klären.
Das machst du jedes Mal. Da wird irgendwie so, ja ich stehe im Zug und der Papsi schreit mich plötzlich an. Wir sind 28 Stunden durch Halbosteuropa gefahren, sind angekommen in einer Stadt und ich wollte einfach nur mal Luft tanken, was essen, was trinken. Und da hast du gesagt, nein, wir haben keine Zeit, wir müssen zum Spiel. Wir haben nur 20 Minuten und müssen in den nächsten Zug. Und ich hatte so eine Halskrause und in dem Zug mussten wir uns beeilen, damit wir den Platz kriegen. Das war der Grund, warum ich auch nicht sofort mit Schimpfworten angefangen habe.
Doch.
Ja, na gut, okay. Das weiß ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Sofort eigentlich.
Da sind halt so Momente, an die kann ich mich auch immer nur sehr schämhaft erinnern.
Ich kann dich da noch gut dran erinnern. Da kann ich deinem Gedächtnis ja auf die Sprünge helfen. Also sowas ist einfach nicht so leicht zu analysieren, weil das nicht besonders kompliziert ist. Und da bin ich auch nicht besonders nachtragend. Anders in solchen Szenen wie die Nudelszene oder so, die halt einfach deutlich komplexer sind. Und bei solchen Dingen, wo es tatsächlich ein Problem gibt, das auch nach dem Streit noch nicht gelöst ist, sondern wo der Streit ein Symptom eines fehlenden Problems war, da ist es dann natürlich nicht ganz so einfach, das dann nachzubearbeiten. Aber das funktioniert dann eigentlich auch mit längerem Abstand natürlich. Eine Sache, die zum Beispiel ein bisschen unrealistisch ist am Film, auch bei dieser Nudelszene, mindestens der Tag, wenn nicht die Woche, sind danach auch gelaufen. Also es funktioniert bei so einem heftigen Meltdown. Läuft es nicht so, dass wir dann die Reise einfach fortsetzen, dass ich sage, ja, blöd gelaufen, dann hole ich mir jetzt woanders was zu essen. Sondern das wird länger nach. Das wird gewissermaßen bis heute nach. Es ist immer noch so, dass ich mich nicht damit abfinden kann, dass diese Nudeln noch nicht gegessen werden konnten. Das wird auch bis an mein Lebensende so bleiben. Das ist nichts, was so schnell beendet ist wie im Film.
Auch bei der Bushaltestellenszene, muss man sagen, im Original.
Ich wäre dann gar nicht zur Schule gegangen.
Aber ihr streitet jetzt nicht anders. Weil ihr so oft schon quasi ein Drehbuch vor euren Streit überarbeitet habt. Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass man sich manchmal denkt, ah Moment mal, dieses Schimpfwort habe ich doch das letzte Mal rausredigiert. Vielleicht verwende ich es jetzt dann nicht.
Nein, das Schöne ist ja, was auf jeden Fall an, dass es uns gelingt ist, zwar mit sehr harten Worten zu streiten, oder es ist ja eigentlich gar kein Streiten mehr, es fängt ja eigentlich erst mal mit massiven Beschimpfungen an, bevor wir streiten. Das ist ja eigentlich so eine andere Herangehensweise. Aber es ist schon schön, dass wir bei den Schimpfworten trotzdem sehr achtsam sind. Also das finde ich ist gut gelungen. Aber heute, ob wir heute anders streiten? Also wir streiten weniger, würde ich sagen, auf jeden Fall. Das würde ich sagen. Es gibt also viele Dinge, wo wir vielleicht auch beide irgendwie gar keine Kraft haben, uns über irgendwelche Kleinigkeiten wirklich zu streiten. Wobei, was ist eine Kleinigkeit? Das kann dann schon wieder in der Beurteilung schnell mal zu einem Streit führen.
Aber das würde mich, also wenn es für euch in Ordnung ist, dann würde ich ganz gerne noch so ein bisschen allgemeiner mit euch sprechen, was eben einfach jetzt passiert ist seit dem letzten Tribünengespräch. Da habe ich mir nämlich die Frage gestellt, Jason, ist es für dich eine Erleichterung, dass dich jetzt die, die Umgebung endlich so sieht, wie du ja immer dich schon gefühlt hast, nämlich als Erwachsenen?
Paradoxerweise nicht immer. Also für mich persönlich hat sich ja tatsächlich wenig verändert. Ja, es gibt seitdem ich, also seitdem ich neun bin, gibt es Familienvereinbarungen, die mir endlich alle Rechte zugeschrieben hat, die ich, die man sonst mit 18 so erhält. Und das Einzige, was sich wirklich verändert, ist das Wahlrecht. Und ja, Landtagswahl in meinem Bundesland, wobei ich da auch nicht so richtig Bock drauf habe, sondern das als Pflicht sehe. Ich bin wirklich angekommen, ehrlich gesagt. Das ist so das Einzige, was sich verändert hat. Ansonsten ist es tatsächlich so, dass es an einigen Stellen auch schwieriger geworden ist, weil ich nicht einsehe, dass nur dadurch, dass ich älter werde, also ein rein passives Geschehen, auf das ich keinen Einfluss habe, plötzlich andere Erwartungen an mich gesetzt werden. Meine Selbstständigkeit zum Beispiel hat sich in den letzten fünf, sechs Jahren nicht verändert und auch nicht erhöht. Aber das scheinen alle Menschen irgendwie von mir zu erwarten, wenn ich älter werde. Das möchte ich aber auch gar nicht. Also das ist nichts, woran ich irgendwie scheitere, sondern das ist einfach etwas, was ich nicht für erstrebenswert halte. Und es gibt anscheinend in unserer Gesellschaft und in unserer Kultur ein recht starres, lineares Verständnis des Aufwachsens und was man dann irgendwann in einem bestimmten Alter so erfüllen muss. Und das möchte ich halt in ganz vielen Punkten nicht erfüllen und erfülle es auch einfach nicht. Und deswegen, vor ein paar Jahren war es dann praktisch, dass Menschen mich wie ein Kind behandelt haben und ich das nicht wollte. Und ich mich ständig weigern musste, praktisch als Kind bezeichnet zu werden. Heute bezeichnet mich sogar niemand mehr als Kind. Aber es knüpft Menschen, knüpfen plötzlich Dinge ans Erwachsensein, mit dem ich nicht einverstanden bin. Und mit dem ich mich auch nicht beugen werde, weil ich nicht einsehe, wieso ich mich mit einem anderen Verständnis, das ohne logische Argumente kommt, also es ist ja nicht so, dass Menschen zu mir kommen und sagen, hier, das ist so und so aus dem und dem guten Grund, dann lasse ich mich auch immer gerne überzeugen, ob wenn Menschen einfach nur sagen, ja du bist jetzt 18, deswegen ist das so. Nee. Und deswegen, es sind andere Probleme als vor fünf Jahren, aber es ist gar nicht so viel einfacher geworden.
Und magst du ein Beispiel geben für so eine Erwartungshaltung, die an dich herangetragen wird, die du nicht erfüllen möchtest?
Also das Thema der Selbstständigkeit ist sicherlich eins. Ich bin jetzt in der 13. Klasse und irgendwie scheint es ein normales, also scheint es normal zu sein, dass man jetzt irgendwie nach der Schule dann irgendwann bei den Eltern auszieht. Und ich möchte das gar nicht. Ich möchte, dass das so bleibt, wie es ist. Und das fällt irgendwie Menschen, also an einigen Menschen anscheinend, schwer zu akzeptieren. Oder das Thema Fahrerlaubnis, die ich nicht haben möchte aus verschiedenen Gründen. Gilt anscheinend auch so als so ein Meilenstein zum Erwachsenwerden, irgendwie, was ich nicht so ganz verstehe. Oder auch das Thema romantische Beziehungen, woran ich einfach gar kein Interesse habe und wo ich auch keine keine Anziehung verspüre, ist auch etwas, wo man was irgendwie in unserer Kultur scheinbar als Bedingungen für das Erlangen von Reife zählt. Und ohne jegliches, also ohne jegliche logische Begründung einfach aus der Geschichte heraus erwachsen. Und da verstehe ich halt nicht, wieso ich mich da einstehe. Also ich verstehe es nicht, sondern ich weigere mich, mich dort einfach einzufügen.
Und wie ist das für dich, Mirco? Es war ja so, dass, also Jason hatte immer schon diese unglaubliche Rhetorik vom Hirnschmalz dahinter, ganz zu schweigen. Das hört man in der, also die höheren Autore können sich nochmal das Tribünengespräch von 2019 anhören. Da hört man das und bei euch im Podcast konnte man das ja schon viel länger mitverfolgen. Und dennoch ist dieser Mensch ja einfach gewachsen und älter geworden. Und irgendwann bekommt man auch das physische Aussehen eines Erwachsenen. Was hat sich denn für dich verändert in den letzten Jahren?
Also A hat sich bei mir erstmal verändert, dass ich auch weiter lernen musste. Also dieses Thema Erwartungshaltung gegen ihn gegenüber. Ja, das ist auch bei mir so, dass ich eine andere Erwartungshaltung an meinen 18-jährigen Sohn habe als an meinen 7-jährigen. Und das ist für mich auch immer wieder so ein Lernprozess an der ein oder anderen Stelle. Wir waren jetzt, letzte Woche gab es diesen, waren wir ja bei Stern TV, da gibt es so eine kleine Szene in Elbersberg, wie ich eigentlich so von wegen Luftblase, sondern eigentlich ganz selbstverständlich von ihm erwarte. Okay, wenn wir jetzt da nicht durchgehen können, ja dann sag mir Bescheid, wenn wir weitergehen können, weil ich schon wieder so eine Halskrause hatte irgendwie so. Und dass auch die Zündschnur, egal wie sehr man sich vornimmt, ich meine in dem Moment, wenn man so überlegt, okay das ist jetzt so einer unserer total wichtigen Medienauftritte und trotzdem ist etwas, wo du dann, wenn du da so drinnen bist, so mit allem drum und dran, einfach diese kurze Zündschnur so da ist und da gelingt es auch weiterhin keinem anderen Menschen so ziel sich eine kleine Zündschnur dann auch die Lunde zum Brennen zu bringen.
Ist denn die Zündschnur wirklich so klein?
Ich denke, ja, das weiß Andreas aber auch, oder nicht?
Ja, also wir in unserem Zusammenhang haben wir keine kurze Zündschnur gehabt bislang, oder?
Ja, Moment mal, aber wir kennen ja auch...
Über was sprechen wir jetzt?
Wir kennen jetzt ja auch noch Collini Su, der ja quasi hinter Mirco steht. Deswegen möchte ich das doch so ganz leicht in Frage stellen. Das ist ja eigentlich der eigentliche Wahnsinn, dass man das raushalten konnte aus dem Film.
Das finde ich allerdings auch und das finde ich sehr schade übrigens.
Dass man was genau aus dem Film raushalten kann.
Collini Su ist der vorherige Bezeichnung des Twitter-Accounts, der auch in seiner gesamten Ausrichtung, in seiner Tonalität dir sicherlich in großen Teilen gefallen hätte, aber schon ein bisschen anders war.
Aber gibt es die Tweets dann jetzt noch unter Wochenendrebell?
Die gibt es zum Teil, nicht alle. Da sind sehr, sehr viele weg.
Aber die sind gar nicht mehr da, oder?
Ein paar sehr schöne habe ich als Screenshot tatsächlich noch da. Insbesondere ein paar Reaktionen, die kann ich dir dann zeigen.
Was dein Vater gerade dir vorgeworfen hat, dass du angeblich immer so genau seine Zündchen gefunden hättest, das hat dein Vater bei ganz, ganz vielen Fußballfans gemacht. Dass er, egal welches Vereins, bevorzugt aber Bayern-Fans, so genau an die schmerzhafte Stelle hingetwittert hat und sich dann völlig erstaunt gezeigt hat, dass Menschen sich darüber ärgern.
Also Trolling. Ja, das war Trolling. Aber das war halt auch oft Trolling weit über die üblichen Trolling-Grenzen hinaus. Das brauche ich dir nicht sagen. Da bin ich heute noch sehr, sehr dankbar, dass wir überhaupt hier sein können. Weil ich auch dich ganz persönlich erinnere, ja. Da ging es deinen Kindern schlecht. Und da habe ich irgendeinen wirklich... Auch spät nachts hast du dann irgendwas getweetet, weil ich glaube, deine Kinder waren die ganze Zeit gebrochen. Du hast dir echt Sorgen gemacht. Und irgendwas habe ich dann irgendwie so... Ich würde auch kotzen, wenn mein Vater bei anfallen würde. Das war so ein klassischer Kulinissus, würde ich mal so sagen. Die Reaktion kam sehr prompt, aber in der klassischen Max-Ost-Manier. Also wirklich sehr höflich, aber bestimmt wirklich. Und es war etwas, was mich seit Jahren immer wieder beschäftigt, dass ich sage, Mensch, dass der Max eigentlich noch so mit dir spricht, so nach der Situation.
War ich da wirklich noch höflich? Ja.
Höflich aber bestimmt. Du hast mir sehr deutlich mitgeteilt, dass du es nicht in Ordnung findest. Aber das war jetzt nicht so, wie Jason jetzt mal so reagieren würde in der Eskalation. Du kamst ohne Schimpfworte, klar.
Das ist ja faszinierend. Na gut, dann kann es ja ganz so schlimm dann doch nicht gewesen sein.
Gegenüber ASV-Fans hat er sich nie in irgendeiner Weise schlecht verhalten. Das kann ich glaube ich sagen. Da war das Auftreten dann auch langweilig.
Ja, ihr liegt ja schon da unten. Da war dann nicht mehr viel. Ich glaube, das war schon immer so ein bisschen eine FC Bayern Problematik. Das ist auch einfacher natürlich. Das kommt ja dazu. War aber auch im Film dann schade, weil im Film tatsächlich noch so ein, zwei Bayern-Passagen rausgeschnitten wurden. Ich hoffe auf die Outtakes. Da setze ich drauf, dass die da vielleicht noch zum Tragen kommen. Weil da kam das eigentlich auch so ein bisschen durch. Und vielleicht ist das dann auch so ein bisschen, das zeigt, dass ich damit nicht ganz alleine bin. Bei zwei Premieren gab es oft Szenenapplaus. Aber der Moment, wenn der FC Bayern durchgestrichen wird, war tatsächlich so der überraschendste Moment für mich. Wo wir unglaublich, also insbesondere in Essen gut Nähe zum BVB vielleicht, da gab es Standing Ovations während des Films insgesamt. Es war sehr skurril.
Also weil Bayern eben nicht der Lieblingsverein von Jason wird. Was natürlich noch mal eine nachträgliche Niederlage ist für den Verlagsmitarbeiter damals, der das euch, der zweite, glaube ich, der zuständig war für das Buch, der gesagt hat, das Ende müssen wir ändern, kommt doch nach München und dann wird er einfach Bayern fällen. Da bin ich gespannt, was ihr dann morgen bei der Premiere hier in München erlebt. Das mussten wir dann im Nachhinein noch mal sagen. Jason, wie ist denn bei dir noch die Situation weitergegangen? Also du bist jetzt in der 13. Klasse, das hast du gesagt. Was ist der Stand bei deinem Forschungsprojekt, das habe ich mich gefragt. Dein Buch ist ja schon lange erschienen, das war ja schon vor Corona. Aber wie ist da der Stand?
Ich mache das jetzt seit sieben Jahren und es ist immer noch die Chaos-Theorie, aber mittlerweile bin ich so weit, ich habe ja in den Corona-Jahren online an internationalen Wettbewerben teilgenommen und bin jetzt praktisch dabei, also aktuell in einer sehr theoretischen Phase des Projektes, wo ich so ein mathematisches Erklärungsmodell praktisch untersuche und es ist viel einfach rechnen und simulieren und nachdenken. Es ist praktisch zu mehr geworden, als es eigentlich ursprünglich gedacht war, ein bisschen wie unsere Reisen auch.
Aber geht es noch um das Pendel, an dem ein Pendel hängt?
Das war der Anfang des Projekts mit der Chaos-Theorie, dieses Chaos-Pendel, wo man eben zwei Pendel aneinander hängt und dann zeigt sich chaotisches Verhalten. An diesem Pendel ist es mittlerweile gar nicht mehr möglich, meine Forschungsfragen zu untersuchen, weil die Präzision nicht mehr genügt. Und weil es wirklich um etwas Grundlegendes geht. Es geht wirklich um den fundamentalen Aufbau von chaotischen Systemen und die Ursachen dafür, warum sie sich so verhalten, wie sie sich verhalten. Das heißt, es reicht nicht mehr einfach zu messen, wie sie sich verhalten, sondern ich will den tiefer liegenden Grund wissen. Und dafür benötigt es eben sehr abstrakte Erklärungen. Das ist so der aktuelle Stand. Und aktuell ist das ein bisschen in geringerem Umfang. Vielleicht noch einmal die Woche, sodass ich mich tatsächlich damit beschäftige, weil so viele Termine für Wochenendrebellen anliegen. Und das ist dann eher praktisch so eine Art Auszeit, wenn man dann keine Termine für Wochenendrebellen hat, zu sinnieren und nachzudenken über Dinge, über die ich auch sonst noch nachdenke. Und tatsächlich sind diese grundlegenden Fragen zum Aufbau der Welt auch die Dinge, über die ich sonst eigentlich so nachdenke, wenn mein Kopf mal frei ist. Und deswegen, das Forschungsprojekt ist mittlerweile fast so eine Art Freizeitbeschäftigung im Vergleich zu Schule und halt zu den Terminen, die wir so wahrnehmen.
Was muss denn passieren, also wenn du sagen möchtest, was muss denn passieren, dass dein Kopf frei sein kann?
Ich glaube, in letzter Zeit war es relativ selten der Fall. Aber mein Kopf ist frei, wenn er zu arbeiten hat. Wenn in meinem Kopf es arbeitet, wenn ich sehe, Dinge funktionieren so, wie sie funktionieren sollten. Jetzt auf den Premieren zum Beispiel, war mein Kopf tatsächlich frei. Oder auf Zugfahrten, wenn ich davon höre, dass Dinge erledigt werden. Wenn Papst mir sagt, das ist erledigt worden, das ist erledigt worden, das hat so geklappt, dann ist mein Kopf mal kurz frei. Ein freier Kopf ist für mich nicht ein leerer Kopf. Das ist ein bisschen ein Missverständnis, das häufig passiert. Wenn ich zuhause bin und alles ein bisschen unklar ist, es geht nicht voran, dann wirkt das von außen vielleicht statisch und ruhig, weil ich da nur liege. Aber in Wahrheit bin ich gerade so unruhig, wie man nur sein kann. Das geht überhaupt nicht. Die Momente, wo viele meinen, das muss doch gerade rasen in deinem Kopf, auf der Bühne, auf der Premiere in Berlin oder in Essen, als wir der Applaus kamen, das waren Szenen, also Momente purer Entspannung.
Das ist faszinierend. Stimmt es doch noch, eine Frage zum Film, die ich mir gestellt habe. Wie nah ist das Kinderzimmer des Films Jason an deinem Kinderzimmer?
Es ist näher daran an meinem heutigen Zimmer als in meinem Kinderzimmer. Aber grundsätzlich, also ich glaube, es war ja sogar jemand, der sich mein Zimmer angeschaut hat da, richtig? Der hat halt mein aktuelles Zimmer gesehen, so wie es jetzt ist. Und es passt schon, also das, was wir dort so mitgegeben haben als Botschaften, was sehr gut realisiert wurde, ist, dass es so eine Art geordnetes Chaos ist. Also es liegen viele Dinge so herum und viele Dinge haben wir irgendwie so ihren Platz. Und das ist sehr wimmelig alles. Und das ist auch in der Realität so. Also mein Zimmer, egal wo man hinguckt, der Kopf hat eigentlich irgendwas zum Arbeiten und man kann sich überall irgendwas anschauen, so, dass es so nicht langweilig wird. Aber trotzdem ist es keineswegs so, dass alles so komplett wild herum liegt. Und es hat schon sein System, so, was man vielleicht von außen aber nicht so richtig versteht.
Das habe ich meiner Mama früher auch immer gesagt.
Aber das ist tatsächlich gut getroffen und ist das erste und einzige Mal in unserem gesamten Leben. Also wir hatten jetzt auch bei den Medienterminen oft Anfragen, so Home-Story drehen oder sonstiges. Und wir haben immer gesagt, hey, wir machen uns schon nackig im Buch, wir machen uns nackig im Film. Es muss so einen Ort geben, wo so niemand ist, außer Menschen, die uns sehr, sehr nahe stehen. Und die einzige Ausnahme, die wir gemacht haben, ist, dass wir das Bühnenteam quasi für den Film gesagt haben, okay, ihr könnt einmal kommen, weil die gesagt haben, du musst uns das erklären. Wie macht ihr das irgendwie, wenn da so ein Schnipsel Haare irgendwie und dann wird das aufgehoben im Beutel? Und wie sieht Jason's Zimmer aus? Und sie konnten halt die große Erinnerungswand, die war ihnen wichtig, die gab es zu dem Zeitpunkt, als sie da waren, gar nicht mehr, weil es einfach so viel wurde, dass wir gesagt haben, wir packen das jetzt mal alles schön ein bisschen sortiert in Kisten. Aber ich finde, sie haben den so eigentlich wie auch bei der Geschichte, dass man immer so am Anfang gesagt hat, das muss so irgendwo diesen Kern treffen, ohne dass es eins zu eins passt. Und ich glaube, das ist in meinem Zimmer so auch ganz gut gelungen.
Ja, aber das habe ich mich nämlich gefragt, weil es eben doch ein bisschen wimmelig ist. Aber Jason, da bist du mir und meinem Ordnungssystem auch sehr nahe. Ich werde euch mein Arbeitszimmer nicht zeigen, dass es über uns liegt. Aber da sieht es ganz ähnlich aus. Und sobald ich mal aufräume, findet man absolut nichts mehr. Jetzt haben wir im Grunde euch ja über eine ganz lange Zeit schon begleiten dürfen. Ich meine, Andreas ja auch. Erst über Twitter, dann über das Blog, das Buch, jetzt der Film. Was kommt denn als nächstes?
Also da gibt es noch viel, was ich so im Kopf habe.
Das dachte ich mir nämlich.
Als allerallernächstes, also in sehr naher Zukunft, kommt eine Fortsetzung des Buches. Das ist ein zweiter Teil. Wo es praktisch um die Erlebnisse nach 2016 geht, um all das, was wir noch erlebt haben, um unsere Osteuropa-Tour, über die wir dann mal ausführlich erzählen, über unsere Lesereise, auch über mein Forschungsprojekt, über die Familienvereinbarungen, über die Presse- und Medientermine, die wir so wahrgenommen haben, über Leute, mit denen wir in den Stadion gefahren sind, unseren Ausflug nach Glasgow und wirklich alles, was wir so erlebt haben zwischen 2016 und 2020. Diesmal in dialogischer und paritätischer Form. Wir schreiben 50-50 und dadurch kommt unsere Streitkultur auch im Buch zum Tragen. Wir widersprechen uns dann auch in unseren Kapiteln so. Unsere Regel war praktisch so, wir funken uns nicht dazwischen und verbieten uns, über die andere Person zu schreiben. Aber man muss immer mit der Reaktion der anderen Person rechnen, dann im eigenen Kapitel. Eigentlich schreiben wir über dieselben Erlebnisse, aber manchmal liest es sich gar nicht wie dieselben Erlebnisse.
Also ist es ein bisschen wie auf euren Lesungen eigentlich, oder?
Ja, davon ist es ein bisschen inspiriert. Das ist Wochenendrebellen, Chaos auf Augenhöhe. Und das wird noch dieses Jahr erscheinen. Das ist also für die nahe Zukunft. Und dann, wir haben ja auch jetzt auf der Premierenlesung, praktisch mit diesem Buch an meinem 18. Geburtstag, haben wir ja auch unsere Spendenziele wieder erhöht für die Welfare in Evans Abbotts Stiftung, wo wir für Trinkwasserversorgung und sanitäre Anlagen sammeln, die nachhaltig zu errichten. Dieses erhöhte Spendenziel muss ja auch noch irgendwie erst mal wieder erreicht werden, von 100.000 Euro jetzt. Auch das steht dann, also es sollte schneller gehen mit den ersten 50.000 eigentlich. Deswegen steht das in naher Zukunft noch an. Und dann gibt es noch ein paar weitere Pläne, aber die sind noch so in der Konzertphase.
Aber das heißt, das Buch wird jetzt dann noch 2023 erscheinen?
Ja, das sollte eigentlich seit 14 Tagen schon erhältlich sein. Wir haben uns zeitlich ein wenig verschätzt und haben dann gesagt, okay, jetzt mit Biegen und Brechen das irgendwie, egal wie, oder doch jetzt dann in Ruhe die Zeit nochmal nehmen können, um an den letzten Feinheiten auch arbeiten zu können. Wir sind jetzt in der... Lektorat ist durch, wir haben eigentlich soweit alles eingearbeitet, aber wir machen halt, also wir machen das nicht mit dem Verlag, sondern wir machen das ähnlich wie bei Traumschiff Erde, dass wir sagen, okay, das Hardcover kommt als Crowdfunding, weil Jason einen Anspruch hat, wo halt auch viele Verlage dann sagen, sorry, also da wird es für uns dann schwierig gegebenenfalls so ein bisschen. Und die Zeit werden wir uns im Oktober nehmen, aber ich denke, dass das Crowdfunding wahrscheinlich sogar in den nächsten 14 Tagen oder so schon starten kann oder so.
Dann wird dieser Link nachträglich auf jeden Fall in den Shownotes zu finden gewesen sein. Also liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, wenn ihr den jetzt noch nicht habt, dann schaut in ein paar Wochen nochmal vorbei. Dann gibt es auf jeden Fall einen Link zu diesem Crowdfunding. Das heißt, es geht munter weiter. Ich bin sehr, sehr gespannt, was von euch noch zu sehen sein wird. Ich weiß nicht, Andreas, ob du noch Fragen an die beiden hast, bevor wir dann hier sie so langsam entlassen auf ihrem Promo-Tour-Marathon.
Nee, momentan nicht. Und das, was du gerade gesagt hast, Promo-Tour-Marathon. Wir sind jetzt auch eine Dreiviertelstunde dabei. Jetzt überlassen wir den anderen auch noch die Fragen. Ich hoffe, dass wir nicht allzu viele Fragen hatten, die ihr schon 530 Mal beantworten mussten.
Nein, ganz und gar nicht. Ich habe es vorhin dem Max ganz kurz im Vorgespräch gesagt, das ist natürlich auch immer total angenehm, ähnlich wie mit Mara letzte Woche oder so. Das ist halt ein anderes Setup für uns, als wenn du dort bei Stern TV sitzt und sagst, was sagt der Sohn jetzt, was sagt der Sohn jetzt? Ich habe da keine Angst bei ihm insgesamt, aber es ist schon ein Thema. Und beim Rasenfunk war es halt doppelt besonders, weil ich habe es dem Max irgendwann per SMS geschrieben, dass wenn wir uns das nächste Mal sehen, und das ist tatsächlich heute nach ganz langer Zeit der Fall, ich ihm dann auch noch verrate, was der Rasenfunk mit dem Film zu tun hatte. Denn es gab tatsächlich eine Drehbuchversion, wo auch der Rasenfunk noch drin war an sich. Hat es nicht bis ins Finale geschafft, insgesamt leider, was uns wirklich traurig macht. Aber es gab so einen kompletten Handlungsstrang, wo es eigentlich auch um die Gründung von Jasons Podcast ging und wie wichtig ihm Podcasten ist. Richard fand den Ansatz ganz spannend, diese Form von Kommunikation, die ja dann im ersten Schritt auch erstmal nur so sehr einseitig ist, das so ein bisschen zu beleuchten. Und um dann dieses Thema Podcasting durchzubringen, gab es so zwei Stellen, wo dann auch andere Podcasts eine kleine Rolle spielen. Und in der damaligen Version ging es um einen Besuch auf der Süd. Und wo ich den Jason dann frage, wo er will zu wissen, dass die Süd so eine Tribüne ist, wie die Tribüne ist. Und das entgegnet Jason dann in der damaligen Version, dass er das im Rasenfunk gehört hat. Und wir haben dann überlegt, wer könnte der Gast im Rasenfunk gesehen haben? Und wir haben uns dann für den Namen Malte sogar entschieden, weil wir gedacht haben, es gibt einen Malte im nordrhein-westfälischen Raum, der immer sehr, sehr kritisch ist.
Der wäre aber nie im Rasenfunk. Der hasst alles, was ich tue.
Ich weiß, deswegen habe ich gesagt, wenn das der Malte im Rasenfunk gesagt hätte. Und leider ist aber diese komplette Podcast-Sequenz, das war ihnen dann doch eine Spur zu viel, insgesamt, weil es so viele Handlungsstränge gibt. Haben wir sehr bedauert, aber es funktioniert halt leider nicht immer alles.
Vielleicht ein Teil zwei.
Aber der Bonus-Content auf der DVD-Werb wird sehr interessant werden.
Das könnte interessant sein, wenn oder... Ich meine, man weiß es ja nie, was so alles noch passiert. Aber auch ein Teil zwei ist natürlich jetzt, nicht davon abhängig, hätten wir noch was zu erzählen, sondern er wäre tatsächlich insgesamt nur davon abhängig, wie erfolgreich wird Wochenendrebellen Teil eins. Das ist so jetzt die Tage, wo wir Regentänze aufführen werden und sonstiges, um einen guten Start am Wochenende hinzukriegen.
Das ist jetzt schon das zweite Mal, dass etwas knapp in einem Kinofilm nicht vorkommt vom Rasenfunk. Ich hatte mal ein Cameo in der Serie, darf ich das jetzt inzwischen sagen? Inzwischen darf ich das glaube ich sagen, Gute Freunde, die jetzt rauskommen über den FC Bayern in den 70ern. Da habe ich einen Reporter gespielt. Und ich sage es mal so, nachdem ich, also ich war da eben vor Ort und hatte dann so zwei, drei Zeilen Text und so weiter, und nachdem ich nie wieder was von denen gehört habe und auch nicht zur Premiere eingeladen wurde, was mir noch voll und munich versprochen wurde, gehe ich davon aus, diese Szene wird es nicht in die Serie geschafft haben. Eigentlich bin ich mir sogar sicher. Ja, müsst ihr halt dann damit leben, dass das einzige Vorkommen des Rasenfunks in einer großen Produktion dann in der Bayern-Doku ist auf Amazon Prime. Da kommt der Rasenfunk vor. Das ist auch nicht, was ich davon halten soll, aber...
Manchmal sind es halt auch die Zufälle. Vielleicht so als letzte kleine Anekdote, weil das ganz spannend ist, was auf der Essen-Premiere Joachim Kohl hat mein Dad kennengelernt an dem Abend. Das war natürlich mega emotional. Ich hatte dann gesagt, Mensch, wie war das eigentlich mit dem Fansein Borussia Dortmund? Wie eng ist das so? Allein die Frage war schon ein großes Problem. Aber es kam dann raus, dass es tatsächlich so war, wie ich befürchtet hatte. Wir haben irgendwann mal einen Anruf bekommen, und da hieß es, ihr seid ja so darauf hinterher, dass das alles authentisch ist. Und dein Papa ist ja eigentlich Anhänger von Fortuna Düsseldorf. Meinst du, da bestünde die Möglichkeit, dass wir dort Anpassungen vornehmen? Und mein Dad damals so recht laissez faire, so naja, ist egal eigentlich. Und jetzt hat sich herausgestellt, dass das tatsächlich mit einer, nicht eine Bedingung von Joachim Kohl war, aber er sofort gesagt hat, na gut, wenn der Vater Schalke Fan ist, dann könnt ihr es vergessen. Und fand ich total sympathisch. Und auch während der gesamten Premiere, ich saß in Essen bei der Premiere und Publikumspremiere ist dann tatsächlich, das war uns nicht bewusst auch rein stimmungstechnisch noch mal was völlig anderes. Und wie Joachim Kohl, der an dem Abend den Film dann auch auf der Leinwand das erste Mal saß, da so saß und bei jeder BVB-Szene wieder so abgegangen ist mit allen Drohen dran. Es ist wirklich ein unglaublicher Typ. Und ich hätte es im Nachgang, habe ich so ganz, ganz häufig, diese kleine Angst seit Dienstag. Was ist, wenn du damals gesagt hättest, nee, also mein Papa ist Fortuna-Fan, ich hätte dann schon auch gerne, dass das im Film so ist, dann wäre uns Joachim Kohl mehr oder weniger durch die Lappen gegangen, was ich mir, wenn ich es dann irgendwann erfahren hätte, niemals verziehen würde.
Siehst du denn nicht, was deine Liebe zu Fortuna alles kaputt macht?
Aber schließt sich da nicht da ein Kreis hier? Am Anfang geht es darum, den Verein zu finden, und am Ende geht es darum, ja, also so schlimm ist es nicht, wenn er jetzt einen anderen Fan darstellt. Und dann sagt Joachim Kohl, also Schalke-Fan sollte er bitte nicht sein.
Der hat auch schon tatsächlich Rollen abgelehnt deswegen. Das war sehr, sehr skurril. Wir waren dann noch zusammen beim BVB-Screening. Also wir haben ja alle Bundesliga-Vereine, erste, zweite, dritte Liga wurden angeschrieben von Agentur, um inwieweit sie den Film unterstützen. Und es gab total viele Rückmeldungen. Und dann waren wir bei einem BVB-Sonderscreening mit ihm zusammen eingeladen, wo wir einfach so ein bisschen über den Film sprechen. Und ich hatte ein blaues Hemd an. Er hat mich angeguckt, dieser Mann, der sonst eigentlich, der kann ja nicht böse gucken oder so. Also den guckst du ja wirklich an und dann nimmst du dem ja diese Gutmütigkeit, die ist ihm ja ins Gesicht geschrieben. Aber das war so ein Moment, wo ich dann gedacht habe, wo kriegst du jetzt noch mal andere Klamotten her, um aus diesem blauen Hemd rauszukommen, oder? War ein sehr, sehr schöner und sehr, sehr skurriler Moment insgesamt.
Das ist doch schön. Und dann kann ich auch noch an der Stelle verraten, wenn wir jetzt eh so allgemein plaudern. Ich dachte ja erst noch, so toll ich den Film finde, aber muss ich jetzt eine eigene Sendung noch dazu machen, weil ich davon ausgegangen bin, alle Rasenfunk-Hörerinnen und Hörer, die kriegen das sowieso mit, die gehen sowieso in diesen Film. So wie ich ja damals, 2019, auch davon ausgegangen bin, alle Rasenfunk-Hörerinnen und Hörer, die kennen euch schon, deswegen ist es nicht schlimm, dass wir die Folge erst 2019 aufgenommen haben. Aber es war tatsächlich die Rückmeldung aus der Community, deswegen nochmal Danke an dieser Stelle. Es haben mehrere Leute nachgefragt, Mensch, das ist ja toll, und ich habe die euch da, damals habe ich über euch die Wochenendrebellen entdeckt. Und deswegen haben sie sich so gefreut, dann diesen Film zu sehen. Das war für mich wesentlicher Antrieb, das hier nochmal zu machen. Das freut mich total.
Verrückterweise, ich hatte es dir ja am Telefon schon gesagt, war auch keine Bauchpinselei, sehr, sehr häufig eine Rückmeldung, die wir bekommen, dass die Leute nicht sagen, wir kennen euch aus dem Buch, oder wir kennen euch das oder das, sondern wir kennen euch aus dem Rasenfunk insgesamt. Und passt aber dahingehend, ich kann nur allen nahelegen, gegebenenfalls, man kann ja auch so schlecht zum Film verlinken, aber wer auch immer irgendwo mal gegebenenfalls Unsinn über die Wochenendrebellen liest, Tribünengespräch verlinken ist sicherlich dort immer ein guter Weg, um wieder so ein bisschen nah an die Realität dran zu kommen.
Weil ihr euch aber damals so viel Zeit genommen habt, das liegt ja nicht am Rasenfunk, sondern es liegt an euch, schon immer war es so, dass der Rasenfunk auf den Schultern seiner Gäste steht. Und das sind in dem Fall unter anderem die Schultern von Andreas Thies. Andreas, vielen, vielen Dank, dass du hier warst, vielen, vielen Dank, dass du uns exklusiv, meine Güte, das habe ich total unterverkauft, exklusive O-Töne hast du uns mitgebracht. Danke dir, dass du hier mit dabei warst. Und natürlich herzlichen Dank, Mirco und Jason von Juterczenka. Ich wünsche euch allen Erfolg der Welt und aber vor allem, dass ihr weiter... Also wenn du sagst, Jason, dass das gerade so mit die glücklichste Zeit für dich ist, dann bereitet mir das unglaubliche Freude und dann wünsche ich euch beiden einfach, dass ich diese Zeit so lange verlängern möge, in welcher Ausprügung auch immer, wie es möglich ist. Ganz herzlichen Dank euch, dass ihr hier wart.
Vielen, vielen Dank.
Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke ich für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Der Rasenfunk ist und bleibt allein crowdfinanziert. Wir haben hier viele Crowdfinanzierungsfreunde in dieser Runde. rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Da erfahrt ihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann. Alle Informationen zum Film, der am Donnerstag, den 28. September starten wird, werdet ihr natürlich in den Show notes finden. Genauso wie noch Links zum Tribünengespräch. Und dann danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Danke für euer Feedback, das wir bestimmt hierauf erhalten. Und dann habt eine gute Zeit und bleibt gesund. Das war der Rasenfunk.
Wir geben nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.
Rasenfunk unterstützen ihr Knausa.